as JD Bernardi leads us in our Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge Al flag United
States God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all good morning once again I'm Michael
Bose of eeping and as chair of the house
science technology and energy committee
I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
of bills referred to the science
technology and energy committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held at any time please note that
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order I confirm that all
members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporarily contempor
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
available has been made available in the
house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS ledge. state. n.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us today Jennifer four committee
researcher please note that all votes
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote we'll start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also indicate whether anyone is
in the room with you during this meeting
that's required under the right to know
law please call the rooll chairman V are
obviously
here yes
okay representative Thomas here
representa
Harrington representative Harrington
representative Harrington can't get on
for some all right I'll come back to
representative
n
okay represa nor
pres representative PL is here
representative bery present in the
committee room uh representative
Bernardi president in committee I should
have said I'm in the committee room cber
representative cell pres in committee
representative POS present in committee
representative white pres in
committee representative
ssuch uh present I'm in my house in
Portsmith and my wife is in the house
with me but she she just comes in and
out of the room here representative
Kelly
pittz representative Kelly
pittz I'll come back some may me un mute
representative man here at home alone
representative
Ox present at home my husband's in the
house but not in the room with me
representative
I'm here I'm at my home and my wife is
in the house with Meer McGee I'm here
and I'm alone in my office
representative MC
Williams I'm on the road today with my
kids okay but you're on the call I'm
here I'm present I am at home in my
office um the rest of the family is here
because it's school vacation week but
they are elsewhere in the home represent
I'm here uh alone in a room
representative Pas I'm here my wife is
down the hall uh another
real I'll try again for those who did
not answer representative
Harrington representative
n representative Kelly
pittz all right we have uh 18
pres so with 18 persons uh answering the
role call the call of the role we have a
quorum and so we will proceed to
continue our business for the day today
we have three public hearings to conduct
one is a new public hearing the other
two are continued public hearings from
believe a week ago today or possibly
they were on a different day but anyway
that's HB 2113 and HB 315 we will
continue those public hearings later in
the
day I will alert all committee members
to Monday March 8th Monday March 8th is
the day we will meet to finish all exec
sessions of all the bills that we
haven't done finished up to that point
so clear your calendar from Monday March
8th that should be our last
meeting before
cross the crossover and so we will have
disposed of all our bills by that time
so representative Harrington I see us
now online okay yeah I'm uh I whatever
the the link from the calendar didn't
work uh just said it was invalid ID but
the one you sent me work Michael thank
you okay so Jen uh maybe you want to
check into that um representative
Harrington said that the link on the
general calendar House calendar website
is not correct it gives an invalid ID if
you could check into that to make yeah
we we've looked at that if you enter
through the digital calendar that's been
corrected um so everyone at the help
desk is aware um to redirect folks if
anybody has a trouble um
connecting okay suggestion that that be
sent out to the representatives n and
Cali pits that may be the problem well
in the case of Representative not her
she asked for permission to attend a
leadership meeting okay at 10:00 so uh
she was given she was excused from this
public hearing with regard to
representative Cali pittz I have no idea
um but um maybe
someone representative s maybe someone
could get in touch with representative
Cy pitson help her if she needs
assistance yes I I'll do that Mr
chairman okay I'm also resending her her
personal link right now okay great thank
you before I turn the meeting over to uh
Vice chair Thomas to open the public
hearing on HP 549 I have a quick
question for representative crean I keep
reading representative cran about
someone named Grady crean who is
apparently quite a good hockey player
any uh
relation I do not know quite possibly I
know um it was a large you know large
French Canadian family um many years ago
but yeah I don't know if we're related
to him I know we're related to the uh
former prime minister of Canada a few
Generations back he's apparently a high
school hockey player in Manchester oh
then quite
possibly most likely but I don't know
okay thank you for sorry satisfying my
curiosity about that
okay so now is the time to uh turn the
meeting over to representative
Thomas thank you Mr chair uh because of
the length of time we have today and the
number of people speaking we will be
limiting uh speakers times strictly to 2
minutes each
uh with the exception of the primary
sponsor which will which will be given
five minutes so with that being said I
would like to introduce representative
oose as as he introduces HP
549 thank you Mr chairman and good
morning committee
members over the last uh several weeks
we've had something like three to four
hours of testimony Andor
discussion about bills that concern
Energy Efficiency and the system
benefits
charge and listening to those
discussions two themes have become very
apparent one that rate paay funded
Energy Efficiency has many benefits for
citizens of our
state and two that managing the savings
targets and the money spent on rate
payer funded Energy Efficiency is a
pretty complicated
ated and time consuming
activity now I've spent quite a few
years as a state legislator struggling
with how to balance the need for Energy
Efficiency which we all agree is a a
substantial
need with a transparent and accountable
process for paying for that Energy
Efficiency and over those four years
it's it's come apparent to me that we
need some kind of a fundamental change
in how we're doing all
this so this morning I'm going to
request that the committee repa retain
House Bill
549 so that we
can explore the possibility of a new way
of doing Energy
Efficiency rate payer funded Energy
Efficiency and paying for
it when I filed this bill so back in uh
the fall my original intent was mostly
to put this eers into statute because I
know from past discussions that a lot of
people were afraid that the legislature
was trying to kill the
eers well that was never my intent I
don't think anybody else in the
legislature had that intent either so I
thought well one way to assuage people's
fears about that would be to put the e
in statute
even the consumer
Advocate has admitted that ERS is an
invention of the Public Utilities
Commission and that putting it in
statute statute would be an appropriate
useful step for the general court to
take
hello yes
hello I can't hear
V you can't hear what you he can't she
can't hear
you can anybody else hear me yeah I can
hear both uh Michael and
Jackie Jackie it must be something on
your
end yeah we hear you
Jackie we did hear you but can you hear
other people when we
speak can you Jackie can you raise your
hand if you hear
anybody she doesn't clearly
Jennifer is there anything you can do to
help her or I would just suggest um a
making sure that your speakers are
turned up and B if they are but you're
still not hearing anything I would just
try disconnecting and reconnecting
sometimes that's enough to um get things
sorted out you'll need a phone call to
have her to have the S her
right Peter can you help her uh
okay jennif Jennifer you were suggesting
that she reboot her computer is that it
or really she may just need to
disconnect from the meeting and
reconnect sometimes that will fix up any
connection problems it looks like she's
doing that because she's gone from the
AUD you got turn the audio there she is
Jackie can you hear us
now can you hear us Jackie
hello well I hate to I hesitate to hold
up the hearing any longer because we
have 13 people who have signed up to
speak so let me just continue on while
Peter works with Jackie to try to get
the her issues
resolved so to pick up where I left
off people were afraid that legislative
office side of the SBC would neuter or
negate the
E therefore putting the erer into law
under pu control seems to me to be a
good way to reassure Energy Efficiency
Advocates that
hello eers be
protected
now the EC the
SBC is probably the most problematic
piece of this Energy Efficiency puzzle
the SBC was also more of a creation of
the P than the legislature while its
existence was allowed under statute it
was never clearly defined as to its
purpose or
use the language of RSA
374f col4 says quote a non- bypassable
and competitively neutral system
benefits charge applied to the use of
the distribution system may be used to
fund public benefits related to the
provision of electricity unquote then it
goes on to say that Energy Efficiency
could be one of those
benefits but the sbc's public
benefits are described in statute as
being to regarding the provision
electricity your
meeting however the commission
interpreted that restriction broadly to
include all types of Energy
Efficiency including what most people
would categorize is thermal energy
efficiency and that broad definition
introduced some ambigu ambiguity into
the understanding of what the SBC was by
the
public furthermore some people have
characterized the SBC as a user fee but
Ray payers who never use the service
must still pay the fee
now that odd definition of a user fee
made the SBC look more like a deao tax
than a fee and that confusion led to
many led many people to interpret that
the SBC is a pseudo tax and should be
under legislative control well when you
take all this together we have a very
confusing situation and this morning I'm
going to propose that
we maybe take a different approach
maybe the best way to do this is to
create a revolving fund on Energy
Efficiency trust fund if you will that
would be funded by the system benefits
charge in the ldac for three to five
years until it
accumulated a sum of money such as $500
million or so at which point the SBC and
the ldac could be
eliminated which would save taxpayers I
mean R payers hundreds of millions of
dollars in the future
without jeopardizing the ability to do
Energy Efficiency so I ask uh this
morning that the
committee retain HB
549 so that we can work to investigate
this approach to Energy
Efficiency funding and with that I'll
take questions and ask people to be
brief because we have for 13 other
speakers you want to
speak representative McGee your hands up
for a question I hope yes thank you Mr
Vice chair uh and thank you for taking
my question question chairman Vose um
you said in your testimony that many
people were confused and that the
process needed transparency and
accountability and I've been involved in
some processes over at the Pu and I
guess my question is since their process
is public and transparent and they have
to have proofs in terms of the benefit
to the rate payers how do we get a
better process for transparency or
accountability when it's currently an
adjudicative process where they have to
actually prove that it's of benefit to
people um to have it work the way that
it does
thank you representative McGee for that
question if you walk out under the
streets of Hollis and uh ask your
neighbors what they know about the
system benefits charge and the
E what kind of answers you think you'll
get a lot of government I would think
answer that rhetorical question by
saying that most people have won't have
a clue about what either the SBC or the
eers is the adjudicative process is
great for
involving uh the cogniz eny of energy
policy but it does nothing to help the
average person understand what these um
what these programs are all about and
yet they're the people who are asked to
pay for these programs so I would argue
that they're not as transparent and
accountable as they may appear on the
surface
thank you okay representative uh oxam
question thank you sir uh yes
representative both I'm a little
bewildered as to how this money is going
to be accumulated in a fund over the
next two to three three to five excuse
me three to five years and at the same
time the money should be available for
those cities firms residents who want to
access the funds to do Energy Efficiency
projects me it's kind of seems like
having your cake and eating it too could
you explain that for
me sure thank you for the question
representative so as I indicated in my
written testimony there needs to be a
fairly complex and multi-tiered approach
to making this work it may require for
example that uh Energy
Efficiency funding may have to come from
a different Source while the Energy
Efficiency trust fund is
sufficiently U populated with SBC and
ldac funds to become operational and so
the devil is always in the details right
we have to work out the details of how
to make this happen but it can be done
uh revolving trust funds are commonly
used in in government for a variety of
of different functions and we just need
time to fixure fure out the exact
methodology for making it happen do I
know all the answers right now no but
that's why I'm asking the committee to
retain the
bill okay representative man for a
[Music]
question please
unmute I'm sorry I I don't have a
question I had a comment
so I will what stop I will stop right
now thank thank
you seeing seeing no other hands we're
going to move on to the next speaker
before we go on to the next speaker I
would like to give a a little bit of
advice please with the amount of time we
have which is short you can make your
your most bang for the buck each speaker
by dispensing with any frivolous
information and go right to your point
please because then it takes a long time
takes at least 30 seconds to say who you
are where you're from uh blah blah blah
all all of that so just go right to your
point we have your information down here
written we we'd appreciate that and it
helps you out too so thank you with that
said our next speaker is Mr Don CH the
OCA Mr CH you are
on thank you and uh good morning
everybody uh good morning chairman Vose
Vice chairman Thomas ranking member
ssuch members of the committee I'm not
going to take up too much of your time
uh because I agree with almost
everything that I heard the
distinguished chairman say uh uh in
particular although he and I I think
come from maybe different points on the
Spectrum when it comes to uh reverence
for or enthusiasm about rate payer
funded Energy Efficiency I I think that
there is a way to meet the concerns of
the Skeptics in trying the Energy
Efficiency resource standard in statute
and create a legal and Regulatory
scenario in uh with which everybody will
be more or less comfortable uh because
there'll be sufficient accountability
there'll be sufficient legislative
guidance to the puc and to the utilities
that run our
programs and sufficient constraints on
near-term spending so that everybody's
electric bills will be uh closer to to
where uh they would like them to be so
if you read my or if you saw my written
testimony you saw that chairman Vose is
suggesting that you do exactly what I
suggested you do which is retain the
bill I am excited uh uh about helping
the committee as much as I can uh
redraft the bill so that it meets um all
of these needs because I think these
things are very uh doable from my
standpoint as an Energy Efficiency
Enthusiast uh the only thing I heard
chairman V say that I didn't agree with
was his suggestion that adjudication at
the Pu is not helpful when it comes to
accountability because it doesn't help
the average person it only helps the
cognis Senti uh my rebuttal to that
would be I'm one of the cognic Senti and
my job is to represent the average
person and I think the reason my office
exists is that there's a legislative
acknowledgement that the average person
doesn't have the time to participate in
pu adjudicative proceedings so I do and
I try to do a decent job of keeping the
interests of the uh average person in
mind so I think I'll stop there and just
say uh I'm eager to work with the
committee as it labors through what I
hope will end up being a retained bill
and I have a lot of optimism that we
will get to a place that more or less
everybody could be comfortable with
thank you m thank you Mr CH I see a hand
up from representative oxam you're up
for a
question thank you very much and thank
you Mr Creer taking my question um you
stated that you agreed with almost
everything that the chairman had stated
and I'd like to ask about this
particular one uh the chairman stated
that some call it a user fee but folks
who never use the surface are paying for
it is that your understanding of how the
system benefit charge
Works um I agree with chairman Vose that
some people do call the system benefits
charge or think of the system benefits
charge as a user fee that that is not
the way I see the at least the Energy
Efficiency portion of the SBC I think
basically it is like the other charges
on your bill a charge that you pay for a
service that you receive and everybody
receives that service because everybody
benefits from cost-effective Energy
Efficiency not just the people who
happen to have the Savvy or the uh
opportunity to participate directly in
the Energy Efficiency programs so I I
hope representative oxam that that is
responsive to your question yes it is
thank you thank you repr representative
samich for a
question uh yes thank thank you uh Mr
chairman for taking this question thank
you uh uh Mr GRE um I wanted to ask you
um are you an a how do you feel about
the idea of the SBC charge being set by
uh the general court instead of by the
Pu well as I said in my written
testimony and as I previously said about
uh house bill I forget the bill number
uh I I do not think that the general
court should be setting rates
essentially ever and as my written
testimony pointed out it's not because
you lack the expertise you probably have
you have at least as much expertise on
this committee as the Public Utilities
Commission has but what you don't have
is the time or the right process in
place to do this right uh and again as I
said in my written testimony the uh
filing that the utilities made at the
beginning of September uh their
three-year Energy Efficiency plan is
almost a thousand pages long uh and if I
was in the hearing room with you uh in
person I would have brought it in and it
down on the witness table and said look
at this I mean most of this is
spreadsheets and detailed technical
information that I'm hardpressed to
understand and I do have the time so uh
so my short answer to your question
representative samich is I I believe
strongly that uh the general court
shouldn't be doing rates and that
perspective is less about me as the rate
payer Advocate and more uh about me as
the former general counsel of the Pu UC
and former law professor who used to
teach administrative law I'm very
concerned about the issues that arise
around legislative delegation and I
think we're all best served when the
legislature offers up clear guidance and
then delegates certain tasks to uh
administrative agencies like the Pu and
setting rates is a classic example of
when delegation is
appropriate thank you sorry for such a
long-winded
answer thank you Rich PR um for For a
Moment I Saw representative Kelly pittz
on screen and with her hand up and now
she's
disappeared is she anywhere to be
seen I guess not Mr chairman I see uh
Representative Vincent I think
indicating his hand there no no okay no
uh I do see representative oxam do you
have a dangling hand or is that another
question you
have forgive me it was dangling
okay seeing no other questions thank you
uh Miss C we're going to move on to our
next speaker thank you Mr
chairman our speaker is uh Susan
Richmond member of the public you have
two minutes please get to your point to
maximize your Effectiveness thank
you okay one more time Susan Richmond
are you you on no okay we'll move on to
our next speaker which is Emily mans
member of the public from Peter bro uh
and on the Peterboro energy committee
you're
on hearing no sound and seeing no
picture we will move on to the next
speaker Cynthia Walter from do New
Hampshire a member of the
public yuron
seeing none I feel like a nighttime
uh radio show host here should we
perhaps um find out if there's a
problem Jennifer can you U I'm
good were you waiting for me no oh good
we were looking for a problem you showed
up and no no problem
I remember I write all this stuff down
um Mr Vice chair it seems likely that
these people signed up when the bill was
going to be acted upon and now that it's
going to be retained they're not
interested in
reporting that could be I will go down
the list to make sure uh Mr Ken Gman are
you on and would you be willing to
talk Donna Reen are you on would you
like to
talk Peter Hansel from
ke
there yeah Don is read I I am here I
would you like to testify um just for a
moment I mean I sent in the written
testimony that you can read um and I
again I wasn't prepared for the decision
today so um uh dear representative V and
honorable members of the st& committee I
am writing an opposition to House Bill
549 um just a couple quick reasons um
the first one is it's well accepted that
Energy Efficiency is usually the least
expensive source of energy at all and I
think it sounds like you agree with that
this bill will strip New Hampshire saves
of much of its authority to offer the
rebates for weathering weatherizing your
home only homes with electric heat is my
understanding would be weatherized homes
heated by oil propan would no longer for
the rebates this change fails to
recognize that weather weatherizing a
home does actually save electricity
insulation keeps a home warmer in the
winter and cooler in the summer anyone
who runs an air conditioner or fans for
cooling knows they use a lot of
electricity which costs more money and
it puts a huge demand on the power grid
in the summertime both are big reasons
for keeping weatherization programs
available especially for lowincome
residents
one
minute at least 10 of the 11 Mayors and
their communities support the 100%
renewable energy goal uh by 2050
weatherization programs are an integral
part of that program for example
conquered is one of the communities that
adopted that uh renewable energy goal
the conquer's en environment energy
climate advisory committee had planned
in April of 2020 to rule out a program
promoting a Citywide effort to
weatherize more homes focused in on
lowincome households because of the
pandemic it's been postponed it's still
planned but been postponed that bill
would stop the financial support in the
rebates so that's the big reason that I
one of the big reasons that I support it
clean energy is our future and it's
under attack in New Hampshire not only
is New Hampshire behind in New England
but in the country and I think this
would put us even more behind so I was
asking you to please vote no thank you
for your time thank you Mr thank you for
keeping it under two
minutes anybody have any
questions seeing no questions thank you
for your testimony we'll move on to Mr
Peter
Hansel you're on for two minutes and um
please just summarize thank you for uh
allowing me to speak um I'll try to keep
my my my comments brief they're similar
to the previous speaker I am a chair of
the Keen energy climate committee which
is tasked with uh implementing our
energy plan which was just passed by our
city council in January uh we have the
same objectives of 100% energy renewable
energy uh over the next several decades
one of the key components of that is
reducing energy use uh it doesn't matter
how uh how much energy you turn to
renewable if you're consuming way too
much en in the first place so anything
that that uh uh restricts our ability to
reduce and conserve uh energy use would
be uh a problem for us we're we're going
to be initiating uh weatherizing
campaigns and other energy saving uh
programs in Keen starting right now uh
we're we're ready to go and if um HB 549
classes that will restrict our ability
to to implement these so I I urge you to
vote no or retain it as the uh sponsor
suggested um and I'll leave my comments
at that thank
you thank you Mr Hassel do we have any I
see one hand up from representative
samich you have a
question uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you uh Mr henel for taking my
question um could you elaborate a little
bit about what the city of Kean has done
so far in the in this in the area of
renewable energy and reducing demand and
how has the funding support you got
through the utilities in the state has
assisted you in
that thank you for that question uh
Keane has been a leader I think over the
last several decades in trying to move
uh away from renewable energy and
control our greenhouse gas emissions we
were one of the first that got into that
back in 2004 and we established a
committee way back then which is now
called the energy and climate Committee
of which I'm the chair and over the past
two years we have been figuring out how
we can transition towards more renewable
energy the city of Kean has done a great
job as a municipal entity in uh
establishing renewable energy uses of
their own through uh solar methane gas
use uh and so forth um and we have been
pushing uh solarized uh operations in
Keen uh for for many years and we we've
started to track that in a way that
that's that we're going to be able to
monitor that uh going forward because we
want to make sure we're we're making
progress in that um I can't really
answer how much of that money how much
of that uh transition has occurred
because of things like uh the systems
benefit charges um I I don't have the
answer to that but I I know that if if
we're going to get serious about
weatherization campaigns and converting
to um other forms of energy and
conservation uh of energy we're going to
need any help we can get uh and I can
emphasize that that being transparent
and being stable is uh as important as
anything else uh we want to make sure
that we can we can rely on the sources
of of uh funding that as we go
forward thank you very much thank you uh
I see representative Kelly pittz with
her hand up for a
question please unmute yes
um thank you for taking my question is
it true that Kean sits in a bowl and a
lot of the emission from uh greenhouse
gases that sit in that bowl that Keen is
located in Dees has addressed because a
lot of the emissions came from wood
burning
stoves you're bringing up a good
question uh several years ago uh well
Keen does know about the fact that we
sit in a bowl that is that is a fact of
life that we have to live with and one
of the things that our city did did a
number of years ago was to uh initiate a
program to buy back inefficient uh wood
stoves and get them replaced with more
efficient ones that was a a good program
fairly successful um and it it is
something that we are very cognizant
about anytime that a new uh source of
energy is put in we make sure that it's
not going to add to the uh the bow
effect that we that we live with
may I follow up follow ahead M Mr Hansel
was was there money uh or grants given
from the
[Music]
dees for that
program I am not equipped to answer that
I don't know because I wasn't I'm not a
city official I'm just a
volunteer there was but and and and it
went to good use thank you good thank
you
see no other hands up thank you
uh Mr Hansel and we'll move on to our
next speaker our next speaker will be Mr
Joseph kwasnik for two minutes Mr
kwasnik you're
on uh thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you for the opportunity to provide
comments on this bill uh I might also
add that I do support um retaining this
bill and committee uh let me just say
that house bill
549 I think makes inappropriate changes
to the current status of approval of
each three-year plan of the E and
assistance benefit charge by moving the
approval from a politically neutral
entity the Pu to a highly political
entity the New Hampshire legislature
this change introduces uncertainty to
the approval process puts at Great risk
the progress made to date and future
progress in reducing energy demand in
New Hampshire also want to say that it
provides this bill also provides for
suspension of any scheduled or pending
three-year plan during a declared state
of E see this is an inappropriate
introdu Interruption of the progress
made and to be made in Energy Efficiency
in New Hampshire and offers up only
unnecessary political interference in
the uh eers implementation in addition
it precisely during states of emergency
that the eers threeyear plans need to
proceed as the plans are at their heart
programs to save money for consumers in
New Hampshire help ensure the stability
and resilience of the electric grid and
also preserve much needed jobs in the
industry I might also add uh the bill
also in restricts the use of the SBC to
funding only projects related to the
provision of electricity this is a false
economy and the legislature should not
change the current use of the systems
benefit charge to fund fuel neutral
Energy Efficiency projects and let let
not forget that even oil and gas heating
Sy systems are all electric customers
paying into the system benefit charge I
also want to add that um The Proposal
that representative Vos has made today
is a process that actually is in Fairly
common use within the electric utility
industry it's called on Bill financing
where the utility in many cases put puts
up a fund a revolving fund that can be
used to fund Energy Efficiency and uh
the on Bill financing means that uh
loans are made and they're paid back
through the savings made by the
customers through their bills so I might
offer that that there is uh work that's
been done on that and it does actually
work thank you very much for your time
and happy to take
questions thank you uh M fuzik I'm
looking and I see no hands raised for
questions so thank you oh I see one hand
raised representative McGee please for a
question thank you uh thank you Mr Vice
chair and thank you Mr kwasnik for
taking my question I was just taking
notes while you were speaking so it took
me a little time to read um you said
something about the stability and
reliability of the grid being something
that um that this helped support could
you say a little more about that because
I'm always interested with what happened
in Texas and all that we're doing the
right thing by the stability of how
we're supporting the grid sure I when I
look at the grid uh there's two factors
I always think about one is the uh
Supply in other words the generating
facilities that are providing electrons
to the system but the other side of the
equation is also uh demand reduction and
those are also important uh for the
stability of the grid and I look at
Energy Efficiency I look at uh renewable
energy as load reduction so as we saw in
Texas there wasn't enough generation yet
the demand was also increasing at the
same time therefore putting their Grid
at Great risk and unfortunately
resulting in millions of customers being
taken off off the grid so I see these
resources e and uh renewable energy as
all part of the equation that we need to
actually make sure is in the mix to
preserve and also to protect our the
resiliency of our grid system thank
thank you thank
you thank you uh representative
representative samich you have your hand
up for a question yes thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr kwasnik for taking
my question uh you mentioned briefly in
connection with the SPC charge uh the
all fuels approach uh why do you think
the SPC is a good vehicle to support
various fuels even not just
electricity I think that um when you get
to what we're really trying to achieve
here is really reducing uh carbon
emissions um and also obviously reducing
energy use that's all part of the the
the mix in the equation um I I come back
to the fact that all uh heating
customers whether they're gas electric
um they're using um uh heat pumps or
what have you they're all electric
customers they all pay into the SBC and
I think that it'd be unfair to not uh
have this as a new fuel neutral program
because those folks who are paying into
the SBC that do not have electric
heating they should still benefit from
that program so that's where I come from
and I think it's appropriate and and uh
the right thing to do for consumers in
New
Hampshire thank
you see no other hands up I see one hand
up representative parshall you're on for
question it's a question for you
representative Thomas F May I'm not sure
of how to address uh but um I see that
Emily mans is
online as a attendee
and uh I know she's not able to unmute
probably a technical difficulty but if
you have a second chance to try that
again I think she'd probably appreciate
that I'm sorry that's not relevant to
this conversation but I didn't know
where else to break
in uh yes thank you for that information
I will ask uh miss Emily man if if you
want to testify if you can come
online she's muted I see that could you
could you unmute from your
end I don't believe she can I was
wondering if we could unmute from the
other
end I don't think we can no okay and
unfortunately uh uh when it's at the
other end uh we we have to move on so he
I speak for her then simple question no
you don't want that's fine that's fine
we'll move on thank you so much good
answer thank you I'm going to call on Mr
Michael turot right now for his uh
testimony
Mr turer are you
available hearing and seeing none I'll
move on to Mr Raymond
Burke from the New Hampshire legal
assistants would you like to
talk yes thank you Vice chairman can you
can you hear me yes I can um I I'll be
very brief um appreciate the opportunity
to provide um some comments to the
committee today um as you know New
Hampshire legal assistance is a
Statewide nonprofit Law Firm um and we
um Advocate on behalf of low-income rate
payers before the New Hampshire Public
Utilities Commission um we'll be
submitting some written comments um to
the committee at the end of this hearing
uh about why we believe the bill in its
current form um would negatively impact
the low-income Energy Efficiency program
which um has been in recent years has
been recognized nationally as an
Exemplar exemplary program
um and is critical in the state's
efforts to reduce energy costs for all
New Hampshire rate payers um but given
the way um the hearing is going today um
while we oppose the bill we would uh
support retaining it and working with
the committee and other stakeholders um
uh to try to address the concerns we
have uh and and to improve the bill in a
way that that
um uh more um can support it so I'll
just leave it there I'm happy to take
questions but um we'll rely on refer you
to my uh written comments that will be
submitted thank you Mr Burke I see
representative McGee with her hand up
you're on thank you Mr Vice chair and
thank you Mr Burke for taking my
question uh you said that that our
program uh
is uh recognized as exemplary I guess
nationally so could you say a little bit
more about that so that we have an
understanding of how our programs are
perceived um sure so there's a a
national review done by the American
Council for an energy efficient economy
acle e and they evaluate um your
programs across the country and
recognize exemplary programs uh that
achieve Direct Customer Energy savings
cost Effectiveness um customer service
Innovation Etc um and um uh I forget
exactly when they issued uh this
recognition I could get that to you in
my written comments but they uh have
recognized um two of our programs the
low-income program being one of them um
as um uh exemplary
programs thank you thank you Mr turut I
see representative sonich has a hand up
for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr Burke for taking my question actually
I I I I too would like to know a little
bit about how your program actually help
flow income residents I mean what what
actually are you involved in doing with
them sure so um specifically in in
regard to this bill and and the eers um
we have represented a nonprofit
organization um based out of Manchester
the way home in um the eers proceedings
for several years now and so we H were
involved U most recently in um the um
stakeholder process that took place
prior to the filing of the 2021 to 2023
uh plan provided input uh to the
utilities um based on how our client the
way home thought the plan would impact
low-income rate payers uh we also uh
participated represented them in in the
docket um that it adjudicated the plan
that we're still waiting on a a decision
in um but New Hampshire legal assistants
also participates um in other dockets
before the the P UC uh around rule
making um the electric assistance uh
program we participate represent the way
home on The Advisory Board um so we do
uh varies and we we do represent
individual rate payers uh with issues uh
ranging from uh you know facing
disconnections to accessing programs
like uh fuel assistance or the electric
assistance program um or the low-income
Energy Efficiency program um and and
most recently also particip ipated in
the docket around the impacts the
pandemic is having on rate payers and uh
the agreement that was reached um with
the utilities the Pu staff and others
around
um uh protections for low-income
customers during the
pandemic followup Mr chairman yes one
followup go ahead thank you uh well I
know a number of maybe a year or so ago
maybe two years ago we we heard some
statistics from I think one of your
predecessors uh regarding uh the backlog
for energy audits for lowincome uh
residents and at the time it was
approximately a 10-year backlog for an
energy audit and insulation projects uh
what is the situation at this
point um thank you for that question and
and my comments do address that um it
there's still a years long wait list I I
unfortunately don't have updated numbers
for you the last time numbers were ran
which was prior to the pandemic I
believe there were about a little over
8,000 households that were had been
approved as far as you know they're
income eligible for the program um and
and were interested in Energy Efficiency
or weatherization Services um but we're
waiting for their name to be called um
we would expect based on what we've seen
in the pandemic um that that that that
has not gone down and perhaps has has
gone up um but unfortunately I I don't
have
um uh recent numbers to give you it can
be a little difficult to get that the
Community Action agencies my
understanding is um they don't have um
an easy way of of just pulling that
number from their system there's some uh
manual investigation that has to go on
and so um the last time it was done I
think uh was during the docket for the
uh prior three-year plan and I'm not
sure that we've seen a new number in a
while thank you
uh thank you uh we have two more
speakers and five minutes to go ahead
representative Med you have question for
this speaker or do you want to hold it
for I do thank you thank you make brief
uh I will um you mentioned that you
participated in the current docket and
so in relation to the work that you do
do you have uh do you have any
information for our committee in terms
of where that that agreed upon
three-year plan fits in to um the
discussions that we're having
here um well I can just say that that
the way home um our client supported um
the settlement agreement that that um I
think um you've heard about before you
know that was joined by the utilities
the consumer Advocate clean energy New
Hampshire Conservation law Foundation um
and and we thought um that that
settlement agreement uh that amended the
initial plan um
would help further the low-income Energy
Efficiency program make sure that more
households are served to try to address
the long weight list that we were just
discussing um and also uh would
Implement some uh changes um that we
thought would would add some
flexibility uh and and and um there were
some changes to the offerings uh that
the utilities were were were intending
to provide that we thought were
beneficial for low-income rate payers so
we we supported uh that plan and our
still that excuse me that agreement um
that modified the plan and they still
hoping that the commission will will
approve it and so we we would be
concerned that this bill if it had
passed would have um halted the progress
that um that that plan and that
agreement would make over the next three
years and my written comments again will
address that in a little more detail
thank you thank you uh Mr U Burke seeing
no other hands up we're moving along to
the next speaker we have uh Ethan Cole
member of the public from Lebanon are
you on Mr Cole hello yes thank you for
uh for the
opportunity uh I am a small business
owner um I live in Lebanon New Hampshire
I own a small construction company Earth
share construction we do all kinds of uh
construction projects with a focus on
Energy Efficiency we do a lot of
weatherization work we have five
employees and we've uh grown our Energy
Efficiency work considerably over the
last few years years so we are hoping to
continue growing creating more jobs uh
more good jobs in helping our customers
uh reduce their their energy burden uh
so we work with home performance
customers who are experiencing uh frozen
pipes ice dams um and uncomfortable
homes and so through this program we've
been able to create a lot of happy
customers who are spending Less on
energy and now live in healthier more
durable more comfortable homes so we
oppose this
Bill thank you I see no hands up no
question so uh thank you for Testimony
that was informative thank you we're
gonna move on to our next speaker Mr
Nick
kof conservation law Foundation Mr cof
you're on yes thank you um good morning
chairman Bose honorable members of the
committee my name is Nick cof I'm of the
conservation law foundation and I
appreciate the opportunity to comment
today on HB 549
Energy Efficiency is good for New
Hampshire's economy and for raid payers
since 2002 Energy Efficiency measures
New Hampshire have resulted in
cumulative customer Savings in excess of
$3.4
billion in fact as Dees just announced
last week the state of New Hampshire
itself has saved $45 million from Energy
Efficiency over the past 11 years the
New Hampshire utilities 2021 to 2023
Energy Efficiency plan
which was filed in September 2020 in
furtherance of the ERS would result in
additional customer energy cost Savings
of more than 1.3
billion the Energy Efficiency measures
proposed under the 2021 to 2023 plan are
all costeffective meaning they they're
the lowest cost energy resource this
means that a unit of energy saved
through efficiency under the plan is
less expensive than the total lifetime
cost of a unit of energy from other
resources
by making it less likely that future e
plans would receive approval or
accomplish the same level of savings HB
549 would result in substantially
reduced energy benefits for New
Hampshire residents the provisions in HB
549 requiring legislative approval of
each three-year eers plan and increases
to an enumeration of uses for the SBC
are unworkable and
unrealistic the commission has the
resources and the expert
to evaluate ERS plans and SBC Rays the
2021 to 2023 plan consisted of nearly a
th000 Pages which was followed by the
submission of expert testimony by
multiple
armies in reviewing the plan the
commission conducted five days of
hearings the legislature has delegated
decisions involving the ERS and SBC
rights to the commission because the
commission is prepared to decide the
complex issues that arise under ERS
plans quite simply the legislature lacks
the necessary time and resources to
sufficiently review the Myriad issues
that arise under ERS plans thank you Mr
kov time is up appreciate it we have one
more speaker in two minutes to go uh
representative ssage can you hold your
question for the next
speaker no no I can't Mr chairman it's a
brief brief question anyway then you may
ask a question and get a brief answer
please yes uh thank you Mr C all I
wanted to ask you is can you tell us
just what what the mission of the
conservation law Foundation is and who
you are yeah sure I have a staff
attorney for the conservation law
foundation and we're a nonprofit
environmental advocacy organization that
works in New Hamshire for healthy
communities and a healthy environment
including advancing sound clean energy
policies that reduce pollution and
strengthen the state's economy okay
thank you very much sure thank you thank
you uh uh
Mr COV I appreciate it uh we're going to
move on to our last speaker M Miss mlin
Mino from the I guess from the clean
energy clean energy clean energy New
Hampshire there got it out you're on M
know thank you Mr Vice chairman for the
opportunity to speak on HB 549 uh though
we would support putting the concept of
ERS into law um we would ask that any
significant changes in ERS planning or
implementation not affect back the
pending 2021 to 2023 plan we the
utilities and many stakeholders some of
which you just heard from um in good
faith followed current Law and puc
Orders and invested tremendous amount of
our time and resources to participate in
the planning process and dockit to
review this plan and we would
respectfully ask that that work um be
honored and let the process come to its
conclusion um we really think that
significant changes like were proposed
in House Bill 549 should really be only
considered after um the pending
plan um though the recommendation to
retain HB 549 is a significant
improvement over um passing it we would
still ask for a an itl recommendation
having this bill looming over the
programs would continue uh to offer
consider uncertainty and our local
Energy Efficiency businesses and
employers are harmed by this uncertainty
they're really looking for Clear
direction if they are asked to ramp up
their work and invest in additional
staff and equipment or or are the
programs likely to be taken away Energy
Efficiency is a local investment that
benefits all rate payers and we think
should be an important part of our
economic economic recovery following the
pandemic representative Vose I'd be
happy to discuss with you in more detail
um your idea for a revolving Loan Fund
instead of programs but obviously I
don't have time to do that at this time
thank you thank you very much um there
being no time left no hands raised I
will ask for the reading of the
BL which I guess was in front of
me um we have opposed 204 support 5al Z
and with that being said I declare this
public hearing for 549
you repeat those numbers please we
couldn't hear them I apologize my mic
wasn't on the blue sheet is 204 opposed
five support zero neutral no F uh no
further questions I declare this public
hearing closed thank you
sir thank you representative Thomas for
an excellent job we will take uh a TW
minute or three minute bio break and
then we'll resume the public hearing on
HB 213 see you
shortly
okay pretty good morning
news win that
case are we un mute is the room muted is
room muted Nick no would you like me to
mute the room yes
e for
my
e
e for
okay good morning everyone welcome back
it is now
1107 and I belatedly resume the public
hearing on HB 213
and the first person I will call on is
representative Michael
Harrington who has an amendment that he
would like to introduce to the committee
so representative Harrington the floor
is
yours representative Harrington are you
there
representative Harrington are you back
yet yes I'm here sorry great you have
the
floor okay um I'm sorry about that I was
on actually on the phone with somebody
on another bill but uh this is the the
the amendment I think everybody got uh
hopefully that I sent out can everybody
hear me to start with yes yes okay uh I
sent out the amendment uh Friday uh it's
not exactly my words but it's the words
that the lawyers came up with and what
it basically the amendment does is it
grandfathers in anybody who uses uh
useful thermal energy for obtaining
renewable energy certificates up to
January 1st of next year so that would
be cover any project that's already
getting them and any project that's you
know in the works right now you know and
it gives them another almost 11 months
to implement that and get on board and
that's basically the only change that
was made to the original
Bill okay thank you uh I have a question
with regard about the amendment
representative
Harrington the amendment says that you
can't build one of these systems after
January 1st of 2022 and qualify for
thermal Rex
are there systems that are currently in
development that might not go online
until after January 1st
20 excuse me thank you for the question
uh chairman I I don't um I don't have
specific knowledge of anything but I
thought since uh most of these projects
are I mean I'd even be open to if
someone could come forward and say well
we have a project in wherever that's not
going to go online until February of
2022 I'd be open to making that change I
I thought the giving 11 months out was
probably sufficient but like I say if
there's an actual project out there that
somebody can mention uh I could
certainly say you know they they went
forward with the idea they'd get these
wrecks then we ought to not uh you know
pull the rug out from underneath them
and we could amend the date but I don't
know of any specific
project okay thank you the chair
recognizes representative ssuch for the
question
I'm I'm sorry Mr chairman I forgot to
take my hand
down you have no question okay thank you
those are the questions I always
appreciate Peter thank
you uh seeing no further questions for
representative Harrington we'll turn to
our next
speaker who will
be Mark froling of Kean New Hampshire a
member of the public who is representing
in representing himself Mr Fring are you
available okay he does not appear to be
available his email address is Fring
energy.com
my recollection is that Mr froing has
testified before this committee before
and owns a company that does that makes
and installs wood
boilers yes Mr chairman that's correct
he submitted testimony and and uh I
think one of the towns that he has
worked for to bring in those pellet
burners is my town Hallis there was an
extensive uh letter of testimony on 213
from froling energy okay thank you for
that
represent all right since Mr Fring
doesn't appear to be here we'll call on
our next speaker who is Mr Bruce Burke
of Pittsfield New Hampshire a member of
the public representing
himself Mr Burke are you AV El to
speak apparently
not so Mr chairman could I ask a
question uh representative oxam is
recognized for the question thank you I
have a vague notion that a an
announcement went out that we were going
to be hearing this uh resumed session in
the afternoon I'm wondering if these
people have been ill advised and are
expecting us to take up this bill in at
after one
o'clock um any such announcement was
noticed in the calendar so
um the house rules require a resumed
public hearing to be noticed at least 24
hours in advance and we did that and if
people didn't get the right information
it's unfortunate but um we followed the
rules thank you okay next up is um Mr
Peter Hansel a member of the public
representing
himself he was here earlier so I suspect
he'll still be
here yes thank you for taking my uh
comments um uh uh my fairly brief uh
comments the uh again our our committee
our energy and climate committee I'm the
chair of that and we are in in the
process of implementing this program
which again relies on uh encouraging our
community to switch to renewable energy
in all forms not just electricity but
thermal and transportation uses over the
next several
decades uh and we felt that this this uh
HB 213
would uh hinder that in two ways one is
that the any reduction in the renewable
Port portfolio standard would discourage
the production of renewable energy in
our state and make it more difficult for
Keen to achieve uh the goals that we're
looking for uh and that does include
thermal wrecks as well if those are
eliminated uh they will be less um
incentive to uh to transition away from
uh fossil fuels towards renewable energy
sources um just as a private comment my
my uh own family business in Keen uh a
few years ago uh converted our heating
system from oil to uh a million
btu uh wood chip boiler uh that Fring
energy put in for us you mentioned Fring
earlier and the thermal recks that were
getting for that are certainly uh
important to us and if we had to make
that decision again without the thermal
rexs it probably would have been
something we would have had to take
seriously into account in the in the
whole equation of whether we went
forward with that with that uh process
um so thermal rexs I think are important
and should be kept in uh in the mix and
uh we would hope that you would uh vote
no on um House Bill 213
thank
you thank you very much Mr Hansel a
minute 56 seconds well done are there
any questions I see uh representative
oxenham has her hand raised you're
recognized for a
question excuse me that was just left up
inadvertently okay sorry ssuch is
recognized for a
question yes thank you Mr chairman thank
you Mr Hensel for taking my question um
since we're not all that intimately
familiar with the thermal re system my
understanding is that thermal recks are
are treated differently than like solar
reck and um how how do they work in in
in uh incentivizing for example uh uh
thermal heating systems like the one you
mentioned from your
business thank you for that question and
I'm not an expert on them either uh we
also have a a solar uh uh array on the
top of our roof at at my company and
I've been familiar with the solar Rex
for many years but we are starting now
uh after we've had a a couple of years
of uh uh heating with our new uh wood
chip boiler uh Fring energy is
processing those those thermal RS for us
and they as far as I can see they're
handled very similar to the way that uh
the solar wrecks are handled we get a
check from them from uh uh the
aggregator
um uh quarterly I think it is or maybe
half uh two times a year for what we
have produced with our thermal
recks U followup Mr chairman follow up
um so uh in light of the fact that your
your town of Kean Mr Hansel is uh was
strongly affected by wood burning uh
stoves that were pollution at the time
uh do you feel that there will be a
demand in the future for uh clean U wood
burning facilities or or in um furnaces
in your in your
municipality and is this something that
the business Community there is also
impacted
by uh very good question thank you uh I
know that that was a concern when we
were looking into whether we should
invest in a in a wood chip boiler uh we
went to the city and and talked to them
about that very question and uh
coincidentally the city uh the city and
the school districts have also invested
in wood chip boiler technology mainly
the school district um so it's not new
uh in our municipality and uh we went
over this problem with uh froling and uh
we fairly well convinced they convinced
all of us that the clean technology for
the exhaust is uh perfectly good for for
our uh our our
community thank you very much I don't
know whe that answered your question but
yes it
did okay thank you um representative
McGee has recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you for taking my question I
appreciate it um I actually our My Town
actually is also invested in uh pellet
boilers and did that early on and I
received testimony from our energy
committee um discussing the lowering of
the RPS threshold as devaluing the Rex
which is something we were just talking
about um and the way that they view it
is that it's not a stable investment
environment so I appreciate um that
representative Harrington was saying the
way the bill will be modified by the
amendment is to say that if you've
already invested
uh then you know you won't be affected
going forward but uh how do you see this
affecting future investments in the
state um because I think there are a lot
of towns that are primed at this point
to make the Investments that some of us
made early so I wonder if you could say
something about your experience um in
your town with when you invested and
whether you would make the investment if
this uh Bill were to go into
effect thank you for the question
uh anything that that
incentivizes the in investment in
renewable energy I think should be
encouraged uh we are in a state that
doesn't have a lot of incentives for for
this type of investment and anything
that that draws back on that uh which is
what this would do would be a negative
impact in our in our plans to go forward
with our with our program so uh I see it
as as a negative um for Investments both
on the private level and and at the M
Municipal level thank you Mr Hansel
could I also mention that Mr Burke who
was scheduled to testify somebody sent
me a text saying he's back on the line
and he's able now so I don't I don't
know if you want to acknowledge
Him thank you I do see him so I will uh
seen no more questions for um Mr
Wheeler no yes Mr
Hansel I will call on Mr Burke from
Pittsfield New
Hampshire Mr Burke you have the floor
for uh two
minutes don't forget to
unmute good morning um Mr chairman and
committee Members First uh I would like
to offer my thanks to the committee uh
whether we agree on policy or not I am
uh deeply moved by how much time you all
have invested in our state so thank you
very much for that uh I oppose House
Bill 213 because I think it seeks it
doesn't seek it decreases percentages
for both class one and class two thermal
power the three points that I'd like to
make why I oppose this bill one over the
weekend I sent you a report from Synergy
energy 20 20 which said that uh behind
the meter solar which this is connected
to saves as much as 11 cents per
kilowatt hour for New England from 2014
to
2019 they go on to say quote as a result
more BT more PTM solar not only
decreases the quantity of electricity
produced it also reduces the price paid
for electricity which benefits all New
England tax pay payers rate payers which
I think has been a concern of this
committee from 2002 2014 to
2019 solar behind the meter saved over a
billion dollars in energy benefits for
New England uh we produced less
electricity which reduced overall
electricity prices they go on to say
that in terms of health CO2 emissions
over these five years decreased by 4.6
million tons that is like taking a
million cars off the
highway
two I think that the renewable portfolio
standard is the only state standard we
have for renewable energy and Thermo
electricity we are behind other states
30 seconds to meet these goals so I
would say very quickly if my time is up
you know that each one of the class one
and class two reduces these standards
and it is not to the benefit of our
climate or our jobs in New Hampshire
thank you
thank you Mr Burke we appreciate your
testimony any questions for Mr
Burke seeing none I will call on our
final speaker for this resumed Public
public hearing and that is Jim
wheeler a member of the public who is
representing the city of
Berlin you are next you have the floor
for two minutes thank you chairman Bo
and members of the committee I really
appreciate the time uh you're giving
everyone including the city of Berlin
today uh I want to talk specifically
about House Bill 13 with regard to its
impact on the city and um that would
come through its impact on Burgess
biopower which um I suspect you've uh
heard over the years how important
Burgess is to the forest industry uh and
in particular to the the uh business
climate in the northern part of the
state
so I I want to Echo uh that theme with
regard to what's important to uh jobs
and the
economy um since the demise of the paper
industry the city's made great strides
uh with reforming our economy and
Burgess has been at the center of that
transformation uh besides the regional
impact uh with direct and indirect
jobs Burgess is the city's largest
taxpayer um we're estimating a tax
payment of approximately 1.8
million uh to the city this upcoming
year put that in perspective uh we will
raise approximately 18 million total in
local tax dollars this year so burges
will represent
10% uh of uh property tax revenue coming
into the
city so given their importance we've got
every motivation to see that Burgess is
success
successful and uh we work with them uh
as often as we can uh to make sure that
happens one of the ways we're working
with them is uh to help uh them find
uses for their thermal energy uh they've
got a vast amount of thermal energy as a
byproduct of power
generation and uh with every BTU of
thermal energy they can use burgus
becomes a more and more energy efficient
facility
so an example uh of one of the ways
we're working with them is we are
planning a downtown reconstruction
project uh this downtown reconstruction
project has a um a component of it that
utilizes thermal energy from
Burgess we're going to use it both to um
provide heat to businesses uh and public
buildings in the
downtown and to remove snow and ice um
so we want to use the lowcost heat as an
attraction for economic development of
businesses in the downtown this
concept's uh been used before and we
actually took it from uh Holland
Michigan which did this in the
1980s and uh their operation continues
on today it's been highly Su
successful um we feel our project is
better than Hollands because we're uh
using renewable energy and Holland
actually um is based on fossil fuel
so last year we applied for a build
Grant under the federal DOT for our
project it's the same same funding
source that conquered applied to and
obtained for its downtown reconstruction
project which I'm sure you're all
familiar with um we weren't successful
last year but in the debriefing that we
obtained or got from the uh Federal uh
management staff at Federal do they
indicated that we scored extremely high
and that
um we you know encouraged us to to make
some amendments to our application and
resubmit and so we are in our planning
stages now uh we're getting ready to
resubmit to build again this
year so the use of thermal energy and
the way that we uh intend to use it is
incentivized through the current recre
program uh House Bill 213 if it moves
forward we'll completely change our
project uh and make it less attractive
for funding and negatively affect our
ongoing Economic Development efforts um
essentially or plainly I'd say that
disincentivizing thermal energy in this
way disincentivizes Energy Efficiency um
which which doesn't seem to make sense
so uh for these reasons and the others
you here today uh the Ci's are asking
you to vote no on host Bill 213 thank
you thank you Mr Wheeler I'm sorry I
didn't identify you as the city manager
of the city of Berlin but you didn't
register that way so I didn't know it
until representative Troy mner who sits
on the committee pointed it out to me
but we appreciate you testifying today
and giving giving us your perspective on
how this bill will affect the city of
Berlin representative burner has a
question and well question comment um to
what uh Mr Willer was talking about uh
we did sign bill 57 which we all
supported in our committee a few years
ago that that's going to run out that
you know that has a a Time cap on it's
the only agreement that we have for pu
agreement for all the new members here
um and part of this project that uh Mr
will has been working on very hard is to
offset that so that they can make that
more efficiency so that when that
expires that they'll be able to keep urg
just open because it'll make it it's
going to make it hard to renew that
agreement down the road with the Pu you
know PC G so your question for Mr
Wheeler is to elaborate a little bit
yeah a little bit just a little bit on
that
J yeah this I mean since since 577
uh it it had a three-year window and so
uh Burgess has been working uh to find
ways to become more energy efficient um
and that primarily will come through the
use of making use of their thermal um
energy so um again that this this
project would consume uh you know a
chunk of that thermal energy and and
would go towards making them more
efficient and making them uh viable
hopefully uh much longer into the future
and uh you know that's why I wanted to
give the committee the uh the context um
with them representing 10% of our local
tax dollars I mean you can imagine uh
what kind of impact that would have if
they no longer
operated thank you Mr Willer I have a
question for you is one of the projects
you're working on a um a greenhouse that
U will grow vegetables year round using
heat from the Burgess biomass plant uh
to keep the green houses warm is that
one of the projects that that is a
project that bir
um is uh considering and working on and
they' come to our planning board about a
year ago um so it's not it's it's it's
entirely on their property so it's
really uh one that they're undertaking
without uh you know without any City
involvement other than coming for PL U
plan review and that sort of
thing okay thank you uh representative
Harrington is recognized for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank we take my
question I guess a quick comment in a
question I'm just want to make sure you
understand that this bill does nothing
to change the class 2 subsidies that
burges will get they'll continue at the
same rate that they are right now and
there will be no change to that
whatsoever do you you agree with
that again I'm no expert on this stuff
my understanding was that they would not
um that that this bill would make them
ineligible for renewable energy credits
for thermal energy well that not okay
let me we're talking about electric
production of class two I I don't
believe that representa Harrington is
allowed to question the testimony he's
the sponsor of this
bill again you correct Peter sorry about
that I'll take it back thanks for
keeping me on my
toes thank you representative s you're
recognized for a
question yes thank you Mr chairman uh Mr
Wheeler uh can you give us an idea of
the environmental um impact that uh that
facility has in Berlin for the region if
I can figure out how to get this stupid
printer to work the right
way all right uh so Mr Wheeler uh could
you uh tell us a little bit about the uh
overall Regional impact of the
employment offered by uh that facility
in your in your in your town sure I mean
they they obviously have uh Direct jobs
of which there are between 25 and 30 on
site uh but then that spirals out um you
know into the woods um into other
logging industry related jobs um my
understanding and the estimates you know
that it goes out to at least 300 U jobs
uh both direct and
indirect uh so you know you have again
without a paper mill here they really
have filled the hole in terms of uh the
forestry in Industry continuing people
out in the woods cutting trees trees
being chipped being brought to the
facility uh it's been fairly significant
quite
significant U followup Mr chairman
follow up so if I understood your your
project that you're working with by bges
on is that uh basically an attempt to
use the waste heat for other purposes
that were not used pre previously that's
exactly right it's it's waste heat
that's currently um well it is waste
it's essentially going to the sky and
what makes this project viable uh which
I I should explain is the proximity of
the plant to our downtown it's uh very
similar to Holland's Holland Michigan
which I mentioned uh they had a power
plant close to their downtown which
makes it um practical to bring the heat
to the downtown I mean I'm I'm sitting
in my office right now at 168 Main
Street I can look out my window and see
the plant uh right across the river um
so we would be taking some of that waste
heat and uh using it beneficially in the
downtown thank you very much okay thank
you representative Pim Andel is
recognized for a question thank you Mr
uh chairman and thank you Mr Wheeler for
uh giving us your time um could you
explain to me uh maybe to all of us a
little bit about the
need for a market for uh lowgrade wood
products in this state and how what
you're doing in the the town of uh
Berlin is working towards that
goal I I I will admit out of the gate I
am not forestry expert um so I don't
know that I can do that well there are
Mr Wheeler if I could just
interrupt stock of the uh New Hampshire
Timberland Association has his hand
raised and is online so if we if you
would like to defer that question to him
I'll call on him once we finish uh all
the questions we have for you that's
fantastic Jay he'll do a much better job
that I will could I do a followup then
okay follow up question and you don't
really have to spend much time uh
answering it but uh there was an article
this morning uh in the conquered monitor
about uh biochar a method for using Uh
lowgrade Wood uh waste and I'm just
wondering if uh the town of Berlin has
uh looked into that at
all I believe that that sounds famili
familiar to me uh I believe that is
something that vergis uh has considered
I'm I internally where that is in their
discussions I don't know but it I I have
heard that before thank you you're
welcome and thank you uh Mr wheer for
being here I'm sure Mr stock when he's
allowed to speak can also speak to the
biochar question but uh before we
recognize Mr stock there is one more
question from JD bernardy who was
recognized to speak thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you Mr Wheeler uh can
you tell us the timeline that you have
for this expansion given the fact that
the uh the amendment that we've heard
grandfathers all the current uses what
what is the timeline for completion of
your expansion efforts We Will We Will
reapply um to build uh this
spring so I believe applications are due
in April
typically the uh responses on whether
you're successful or not um come in
September and once you're notified if
you're
successful it it there is a a I think
it's about a threeyear
window um between notification and
actual uh start of construction so that
that's the time frame that we would be
looking at
okay followup follow up so three years
from Once the grant has been authorized
to
completion of the project to make it
functional is that what we're talk three
years until start of construction and
then of course you'd have the
construction window so I I think for a
project this large we would be talking
something longer than a year so to be
safe might as well say two years so five
I guess you could say five years from
September of 2021 is when the project
would be
complete thank you you're welcome okay
thank you Mr Wheeler see okay one more
question representative McGee is
authorized for a question thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you Mr Wheeler for
taking my question so based on what you
were just saying about the time uh the
length of time that a project would take
to come online would would implementing
this bill Bill saying that as of 2022
there would be a cut off for people who
would be eligible would that affect uh
the decision to go forward with the
project in terms of the U economics of
it it it would probably cause us to
rethink the project um and it may kill
the project in the way that we've
thought about
it one of the reasons we have this
component of waste heat in the project
is because it's innov
and uh the way we've been able to
include it it's Transportation related
and you know and we've been told Again
by the federal do that um why our
project is attractive because it has
this is because it has this
component so uh a build Grant would pro
pro may not become or may not be um as
attractive and we may have to pursue
other methods I guess of funding I guess
that's
time would only tell but I suspect we
would have to rethink our funding
strategy and okay
oh followup I I just had a thought with
what we have stop in 20 minutes go ahead
and follow up yeah the the followup was
just you mentioned that the concept of
using the waste heat was Innovative and
I'm curious whether that Innovation was
the result of the fact that there was a
program that you were participating in
or that Burgess was partic participating
in I would say from very early on in the
concept of the project uh yes the rec
program was one of the things that we
thought would make our project viable it
it was not a it was by no means an
afterthought it was something that we
thought about early on and is important
to to
Burgess okay thank you very much you're
welcome thank
you thank you and thank you Mr Willer
for being here we really appreciate it I
would like to Now call on Jason stock
who represents the new Hamp New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
Mr stock uh the floor is yours good good
morning can you hear me yes we can okay
before you start the ticker um I just
wanted to make you aware that the link
on the PDF of the calendar isn't working
and there are I know a bunch of people
that signed up to
testify on the original Bill last week
and we're on the list that we that were
that are hoping to testify today so um
they're raising their hands so I just
wanted to make you aware that part of
the reason why you may not be hearing
from Mr froling and Company and others I
know some of my members they ran into
some technical glitches getting onto the
meeting um just to make you aware that I
did email the folks on the uh on on the
calendar to make them aware of it but um
I'll I'll start my testimony now and and
for the just by way of background Jason
stock New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association we represent land owners in
the state forest products
industry um we have about 1300 members
who own and manage about a million Acres
of of Timberland in the state of New
Hampshire um and New Hampshire is uh
about two-thirds of all that wood that's
standing as low grade unable to make
Lumber or any or higher quality products
um such as veneer or Lumber um annually
about three to three and a half million
green tons of wood all species all
product are are are harvested in the
state and when you look at that about a
million of that is chipped that's wood
that's chipped for generally energy
purposes either going into a pellet
Market or going to an energy project um
and so you know in as much as House Bill
213 which we oppose um in as much as
that hurts the RPS program and quite
quite suely goes after class three
biomass and the thermal credit we're
we're testifying in in a an opposition
to it the other piece of the of the um
puzzle here is that even the Mills the
higher grade products they they produce
chips that also need a market um you
take a round l you make Square Lumber
you chip that slab those are those need
to go to uh go to markets as well um and
when I when we look at the original
purpose of the RPS law biomass and and
energy um both thermal and heat or
thermal and and electricity really hits
several of the key cornerstones fuel
fuel diversity Timber has cut over in
almost every town every year in the
state of New Hampshire there's about 2,
to 2500 Timber sales a year um keeps the
money local uh you heard from Berlin the
economic activity occurring there when
you look at the six biomass plants
historically they've supported another
$250 million in economic activity 950
jobs thermal consumes about 70,000 tons
a year put that in perspective that's
2500 truckloads of lowgrade wood going
into thermal projects
um environmental benefits I'm not going
to get into you know emissions and all
that what I can tell you and I know this
comes up regularly is is biomass carbon
neutral is it a good fuel um EPA has
determined that it is um and and has has
said yes it is it is carbon neutral um
when we look at growth using US Forest
Service data New Hampshire continues to
grow 84 million cubic feet a year more
wood than is harvested or is lost to
Natural mortality we have a net growth
um thank you carbon sequestration about
2.2 metric tons a year are are
sequestered because these forests are
growing real real quick this is a
dispatchable product or dispatchable
electricity some people will argue it's
it's a it's a subsidy this is a a base
load disp aable power and you know yes
you know if it is a subsidy the the rate
payers are getting something for it
they're getting fuel diversity they're
getting a dispatchable power source
something I'm sure the folks in Texas
would have loved to have had last week
and with respect to the with the the uh
the amendment um and it's not clear how
it affects the bill whether it's just
the the grandfathering provision but
listening to this the sponsor
class three listening to his testimony
class three wood is still
eliminated um and that's that's a huge
problem for us also as you heard from
Berlin it forecloses the opportunity for
Future Energy Efficiency projects at
some of these existing plants such as
Berlin or even projects like green
houses in the in the loud area where you
you have some wood shifts getting used
to make heat for for Greenhouse projects
Mr stock yes can I ask you
um I I can conclude my testimony there
chairman just we we oppose House Bill
2113 thank you understood my question
was going to be that there are several
other people who need to would like to
speak and we only have 12 minutes left
so I was going to ask you if you could
you could finish up but I guess
you right okay thank you and for
committee members I will ask you to hold
your question question so that we can
allow these folks who have requested to
speak to do so our next call on Dennis
chairman point of order here uh I notice
in the attendees list there are as I see
it seven people who have rais their
hands and according to Mr stock uh they
are not having an opportunity to join us
uh can you look into what's going on
there and can we get them are they are
they able to get connected to us or not
yes uh thank you for that question
representative s the fact that you can
see them in the attendee list with their
hands raised means that they are
connected and I was trying to get as
many of them online as possible before
our hard stop at 12 o'clock thank you
very much so I recognize now Mr D Dennis
D mckenny I believe it is Mr McKenna you
have two minutes
thank you Mr chairman I'm a land owner a
Forester and a business owner as well as
an eversource rate paay in Bennington
New Hampshire I've been in this area for
40 years our company has had a forestry
Consulting office in this area since
just after World War II I would just
highlight a few points from my written
testimony which I emailed the committee
I also am opposed to House Bill
2113 uh in its elimination of class
three existing biomass from this
standard these markets are vital to land
owners and Timber Harvesters in the
entire Forest products industry across
the entire State it's a very important
forestry tool and just this segment of
the forest products industry uh was
recently determined to contribute about
a quarter of a billion dollars to the
state's gross domestic product
specifically in my work for every load
of highquality Saw logs which we
responsibly Harvest from a site we
typically generate two or more tractor
trailer loads of lowquality chips and
roundwood and if you don't weed your
garden you don't have much of a
vegetable garden at the end of the
season it's a homegrown renewable and
reliable source of electric power thank
you
thank you I appreciate your testimony
for being here next I call on Mark
froling Mr fr you have two
minutes thank you Michael B uh thank you
committee members um my name is Mark
froling and I'm um an opponent of this
house bill
213 and um so I'm in strong opposition
of this bill and um we have a tremendous
amount of money invested in
um utilizing the Rex so when the rec
bill came around and it was put into
position we heavily
invested um in in our technology which
is in fact boiler installations and dry
chip manufacturing which generates more
thermal recks and we um with our
technology and with our services we
produce about onethird of all the Recs
in the state of New Hampshire and we
have recently made an enormous
investment really all of my personal
belongings have gone into this
investment and this house build 213 um
will take all of this away my personal
workings of my entire life will go down
the tubes with this really um just a
poor Bill really all together and I um
obviously you know I had some
difficulties getting on this site here
today but I'm just really upset about
how this bill could get even to this
stage and how this could get proposed it
is really a shame we have really good
employees we have a tremendous amount of
biomass suppliers to our facility we
have trucks rolling in as I'm speaking
here and this would be a
devastating would have a de devastating
effect on our company and my own
livelihood and the 15 employees that we
have
here indirect employees that we employ
through
subcontractors um the T-Rex is one of
the best things that has happened to our
industry and so I'm supporting those but
not this Bill thank you thank you
exactly two minutes well done sir okay
next I will call on Morgan dicks you
have two minutes go
ahead uh thank thank you for the
opportunity to speak to the committee
today concerning HB
213 I am the founder and president of
DCI a family-owned business located in
Lisbon we employ 180 employees and are
one of the larger employees Employers in
the North Country my company is an
integral part of the forest economy
purchasing logs wood chips Trucking and
many other services this bill if passed
will have a severely negative impact on
my company and local Forest
economy our company manufactures
furniture for the United States military
and public and private colleges
including UNH Plymouth State and
Dartmouth we ship our product to Basin
all over the world the lisban facility
is quite large contains over five acres
of buildings we heat our buildings and
dry kils solely with wood waste from our
operation and locally sourced wood chips
we use zero fossil
fuels until last year we had two
Woodfired boilers but under pressure
from the New Hampshire Dees we were
required to shut down one of the boilers
leaving us with a 40-year-old boiler and
no backup for 2 years we have been
working on a plan to replace the current
inefficient boiler with a new high
efficiency boiler equipped with the
latest technology for biomass combustion
seconds we have completed feasibility
studies and spend hours planning this is
a $2.8 million project and the company
needs to obtain financing for the boiler
T-Rex are critical to the success of the
project and provided the ability for the
company to justify financing 15 seconds
T-Rex provides companies like mine
hospitals and schools the incentive to
invest in clean renewable biomass
combustion in our case the new boiler if
we are successful in obtaining financing
will remove over 20,000 pounds of
particulate annually from the atmosphere
thank you and I urge you to vote against
this will thank you very much Mr dicks
we appreciate your testimony this
morning I now call
on uh Matt Ley Mr Ley you have two
minutes uh good morning Mr chairman I
will be less than that I hope you all
can hear me uh we did uh I'm this is
Matt Ley I'm with the for society uh we
did submit written testimony uh in
opposition to this bill if you didn't
get it I'll be happy to resend it but
just quickly our opposition to this bill
is based on the fundamental purpose of
the RPS which um as you know is to um
increase the use of local renewable
fuels um and reduce the use of you know
our dependence on fossil fuels and we
just look at the um Bill's language you
know for example it's treatment of class
one thermal um as in direct opposition
you know to the fundamental purpose of
of the RPS and therefore we would ask
you to um oppose its Bill thank you
thank you I appreciate uh your being
brief we'll next call on Mr Derek
Freeland Mr Freeland you have two
minutes uh good morning Mr chair ladies
and gentlemen of the committee uh thank
you for the opportunity to speak today
my name is Derek furland I'm the County
Manager for Sullivan County and on
behalf of the Board of Commissioners I'm
testifying today in opposition of HB
2113 Sullivan would lose $100,000 a year
in Revenue which would most likely be
offset by higher property taxes Sullivan
County's taxpayers are not alone in this
regard as chesher marac and Rockingham
counties also have biomass plants and
generate s similar
revenues uh since 2014 when Sullivan
County invested $3.4 million to convert
to biomass for heat we have saved
hundreds of thousands of dollars buying
wood chips compared to fuel oil in 2019
however we invested Ed another $300,000
to reduce our particulate emissions in
order to qualify for T-Rex T-Rex have
provided the financial incentive to make
these Investments therefore we should
consider the RPS as an investment not a
subsidy New Hampshire consumers spend
over $600 million annually on fuel oil
and the T-Rex portion of the RPS drives
investment in biomass systems which
helps capture a greater share of this
heating oil Market
nothing says Made in New Hampshire like
wood chips they are locally produced
locally processed and locally
transported uh T-Rex are a strategic
Catalyst for New Hampshire's economy by
providing markets for low-grade wood
products and incentives to proactively
manage our forests sound Forest
management as we heard last week
decreases the risk of wildfires which
would be devastating to New Hampshire's
tourism economy between the jobs that
are created and sustained due to the
demand for wood chips and the
preservation of our natural resources
that impacts tourism T-Rex are the very
definition of a strategic asset
including T-Rex in the RPS is good
policy for New Hampshire in fact we
should be doing more not less to try and
capture a greater share of the annual
$600 million 80% of which leaves New
Hampshire and benefits others
grandfathering
exist thank you very much for being here
today and for
testifying uh I'll next call on Heidi
Crow
Miss croll if you could uh keep Mr
chairman really I must protest we were
asked to delay our questions from one
speaker to another that speaker we would
no questions were taken no questions
have been taken on the last I think it's
four speakers if we need more time we
can this hard stop at 12 o'clock is
purely artificial we can move we can
move further this testimony is important
and I I really do think that you're not
treating our the the public and the
members who have come forward to speak
to us in a respectful fashion by
treating them in such an Abrupt and
off-hand fashion thank you for
registering your point of order I will
tell you that for the members who have a
hard stop at 12 o'clock it's not
arbitrary they have reasons why they
have a hard stop there are members of
this committee sitting here in this room
who work and they have obligations to
their employers so it's it's not an
arbitrary hard stop it's a real hard
Stop Now by uh introducing this point of
order discussion into the into the mix
you have uh prevented several people
from being a able to
testify because now we've reached our
hard stock so I hope you feel good about
that I'm going to uh recess this public
hearing and we'll talk later about when
and if it ever resumes so thank you
right now and we'll see you at one
o'clock Mr chairman I don't see any
reason why you couldn't resume at 1
o'clock why you couldn't recess this
hearing and resume again at one o'clock
for another 10 minutes or so right house
rules state that if you re recess a
public hearing and resume it you have to
give it a Time certain so we have to
resume the public hearing at for HB 315
at one o'clock time you can resume it
and then postpone it right just like you
do with other hearings we could resume
it and then recess it I'll doing that at
one o'clock but not until then so we'll
see you at one o'clock take care making
this up so what are people to understand
about whether they should come back to
testify on 2113 I don't I don't
understand what you're
saying
okay I guess people get no Direction I
think the room has been turned
off just nothing matters except the
time I also would be fine with a shorter
lunch but
alas we are not in
church are there any rules about this
situation I
wonder John can you contact the clerk's
office yeah I think it's worth it yeah
thanks yep thank you I'll take care of
that I don't understand what's going
on for
e
e e
Mr chairman can I ask a question
are we un
muted yes okay yes you may ask a
question thank you Mr chairman um I got
a note over lunch period saying that
both of the links in the calendar to our
to our 11 and our 1M sessions that were
added both of the links were not working
for the public so I just wanted you to
be aware of that I wasn't sure if you
had
heard yes I did hear I just got email
from HCS which is house Community
Services yep and they Pro provided a
updated link to Mr C Clifton vo okay I
don't know if they have fixed it on the
house calendar or
not but they're aware of it and so
they're trying to make people hold okay
thank you you get that
opportunity for
representative mgee uh Mr Belo is now
online so apparently the revised link
that he was sent is
working and uh I would trust that
anybody else who has contacted
HCS has also received a updated link
that works so hopefully
everybody who wants to be on the on the
call is own the call at this
point okay so it is uh one o'clock
and I would like to uh remind everybody
that at 12 o'clock I recessed I did not
conclude I did not adjourn HB 23's
public hearing I recessed it and we will
now resume the public hearing on HB
213 and after consultation with the
house clerk I have determined that we
can finish this public hearing before we
have to open the public hearing on HB
315 so we will do that uh at the
conclusion of the public hearing on
hb2 213 so that I will call on Heidi
Crow and Miss Crow I will give you two
minutes to make a
presentation thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh good
afternoon uh for the record my name is
Heidi croll I'm testifying today on
behalf of the Granite State Hydro Power
Association um I did submit written
testimony um gsha is opposed to um House
Bill 213 and would respectfully urge the
committee to find it inexpedient to
legislate um we're opposing because it
will undermine the um RPS program um and
while um so 213 would lower the
percentage requirement for class one and
while existing Hydro facilities are not
typically associated with class one um
there are about uh five or six um of New
Hampshire's smallscale Hydro facilities
that are eligible to participate to some
extent in class one because they
completed uh Capital Investments such as
efficiency improvements or additions of
capacity um that resulted in incremental
new production of electricity um so the
proposal in house bille 213 to lower the
class One requirement to 6% um per
compliance year would uh negatively
impact the class one um wreck Market by
causing the value of um class one rexs
to um to drop substantially and in turn
um harm the ongoing economic viability
of the existing um smallscale Hydro
facilities that are participating in
class one um New Hampshire class 1 Rex
provided much provide much needed
financial support to the ongoing
operation of several um of New
Hampshire's uh hydroelectric projects uh
whose owners decisions to upgrade their
Hydro facilities included um you know
some some trust I guess that the
legislators uh or legislature would not
um 30 seconds destabilize the state's
RPS program um with that I will um seed
the rest of my time to uh other speakers
we appreciate it um and uh thank you for
taking my testimony and again we are um
support uh an itl motion on House Bill
213 thank you thank you Miss Crow
representative s samich is recognized
for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
Miss Crow um you tell me if if um HB
2113 were P what do you see as the
consequences for your members in as are
is planning for the
future well like I said there there are
um about you know half a dozen or so
smallscale Hydro facilities that have um
made um upgrades to their facilities um
that and that marginal um additional
output that those upgrades um produced
if you will uh that's the piece that's
um eligible for for class one and so
those um Investments were made
um with the understanding that um you
know the class one recck market would
kind of um not be disrupted um you know
in addition I think uh so so you know
one there's there's uh Investments kind
of hanging in the balance there um and
in addition I you know would just say
that in general small scale Hydro
facilities um they're they're FK
regulated they're uh regulated by the
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission um
they uh have to adhere to a very high
standard of Maintenance and um
documentation um you know they they are
subject to the same uh firk requirements
that a larger scale Hydro facilities are
but of course they don't have the
economies of scale that the larger ones
do um they many projects are required to
install and maintain um expensive um
fish passage facilities um the latest uh
has been um around eels um the eel
passages are are very expensive um in
some cases they are uh the hydro
facilities are required to shut down
generation for short periods of time to
allow the safe passage um Downstream
passage of eels um so um I think to
answer your your question uh you know
the RPS plays a very um important role
to hydro uh
projects who are you know especially the
small scale run of river ones that are
sensitive to annual variations in
wholesale Energy prices and and also um
water flow you know we had a drought
this year so their revenue is down
because their generation was
down thank you thank you miss croll
seeing no further questions for Miss
croll I'll call on our next speaker who
is Charlie Marino Mr Marino you have the
floor for two
minutes thank you Mr chairman can you
hear me
yes okay thank you I'm uh Charlie Moreno
from straford New Hampshire and today
I'm focusing on how anti-b business and
economically devastating HB 213 is I
present my business as an example of the
hundreds of forest industry businesses
in the state I started my business
Moreno forestry in 1980 when I was 21
years old and have operated successfully
for over 40 years our sustainably
managed forests in the Sea Coast Area
produce about 4,000 trailer loads of
wood annually parked end to end this
line of trailer trucks would be over 50
miles long two-thirds of these trucks
are filled with chipwood and HP 2113
would be devastating to our business in
40 Years of business I've never received
a dime of financial assistance from the
state of New Hampshire nor would I want
any and like a thousand or so other
Forest industry businesses in the state
we all deliver jobs taxes and robust
economic
activity $250 Million worth of economic
IC activity annually representative
Harrington's misinformed attack on the
forest industry starts off with
mischaracterizing the rec credits as a
subsidy Rec credits are not a subsidy in
my opinion they are earned by the
biomass plants for investing and
producing Power by renewable means the
use of the term subsidy disparages the
forest industry which is an industry
that is staunchly independent and
self-reliant this industry contributes
jobs taxes and economic wealth to New
Hampshire's econ economy to the tune of
$250 million 30
second not much has been said about the
90,000 Forest land owners in New
Hampshire that this bill hurts this loss
of New Hampshire's wood energy plants is
an automatic 25% discount on the timber
value of most people's wood Lots many of
these land owners provide free hunting
snowmobiling and Hiking as well as water
and air quality benefits and they don't
get compensation at all this bill
creates a huge financial setback to hter
land owners and it makes mockery of
their enormous generosity in providing
free public access to their private
Forest as a New Hampshire business owner
I'm here to ask that you not support
this poorly conceed bill it's anti- jobs
anti-land owner and anti Forest please
support CZ and land owners and vote this
down thank you Mr chairman Mr
Mar thank you Mr Marino appreciate that
um representative pimel is recognized
for a
question uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Mr Moreno for being here to uh
discuss this
issue one of the questions I have is uh
basically the what impact this will have
to the uh
the lowgrade wood market and what impact
that will have on the state in general
I'm talking about uh forestry
management
um uh sports
activities tourist tourist uh business
Etc uh yes thank you representative it's
devastating um our forest management and
our for depend on maintenance as has
been stated before by several other
speakers and without this lowgrade
Market the chipwood market is absolutely
critical um as you can see two-thirds of
our forest products are are that um
without that market our forest would be
uh just a Haven for the insects that are
are attacking it right now um for uh
we've heard of the fire dangers and
there's no way we can grow better
healthier forest or or the uh or
provides the habitat benefits that we do
um this is vast we we'd be losing that
so I really urge you not to support this
bill follow up Mr chairman follow up so
the other question I have concerns the
uh the lumber Market how will that
affect uh the timber industry as far as
uh harvestable Lumber and how they deal
with u basically a product that is all
of a sudden of no
value if if we no longer have the
chipwood market you're going to see just
High grading of the forest the only
thing that's you know worth cutting is
is good trees and the poor quality trees
are left um and that'll be a long-term
effect negative effect to our forest
it's it's pretty huge um the the lumber
industry um if if there is any kind of
low-grade Market
um the the high-grade products will be
subsidizing the cost of removing that
low-grade product um so land owners will
lose once again with lower Timber prices
and um the Sawmills themselves need a
home for the chipwood that they generate
when they saw Lumber they end up with
slabwood and and edgings right now
that's sold to uh chip plants um and
they will no longer really have a home
for that so that's higher cost for them
as well so you just see a kind of a
spiraling this is all connected it's a
big Network um and the and the biomass
plants are at the uh in the middle of
all of this so to lose that will be
devastating our our our industry is
already pretty baguer and um and it's uh
a big chunk of of our state's economy um
and it has been for many many years I
mean it's it's part of our our state's
character this a direct attack which
without really a full picture of the uh
the overall
consequence okay Maro thank you Mr
Marino before I recognize the next
questioner I want to announce to those
who are waiting that the public hearing
the resumption of the public hearing on
hb31 15 will'll start as soon as we
finish questioning Mr Marino who appears
to be the last speaker for HB 213 so
with that I recognize representative
McGee for a
question thank you Mr speaker thank you
Mr Moreno um my question is around
something you said I was taking notes
and um you mentioned the
mischaracterization of the Rex as a
subsidy and as I look at some of the
bills that we have that I as I look at
them I'm trying to figure out what
problem we're trying to
solve um this is one of those bills and
so my question to you is could you say a
little bit more about how you see the
Rex in terms of you've mentioned all the
different Downstream benefits that you
see uh the New Hampshire economy
deriving but can you say a little bit
more about how subsidy might not be the
right way to look at it
it's um yeah it's these are incentives
for um power power plants that are
polluting that are using non-renewables
to to come around and and um change that
because this is good for the uh for the
environment it's good for our state and
in so many ways that speaker after
speaker have have delivered today and
the other day um it's an incentive and
those incentive pay payments go to the
the energy producers that are in fact
investing in and producing the renewable
energy power which has so many spin-off
benefits not not only to our uh economy
but to our
environment this is these are long-term
consequences that we need to be thinking
about
today yes I wouldn't call this at all
it's it's a it's a credit and these are
earned by our um our our wood wood
energy plants they're earned
would you also uh when you say it's a
earned credit there's also the local
diversity I mean those are the things
that come into play in my mind in terms
of the aspect that the thermal uh Rec
system plays that might be distinct from
some of the others I mean it's local um
and sustainable is that a question yeah
well I'm trying to trying to get to the
question because you know this idea that
the the benefits are difficult for us
maybe to get our our heads around but
there are significant benefits that are
local and that means that we don't have
to send those dollars out of state they
generate money
here right I I guess the bottom line is
I think it's disparaging to our industry
to call this a subsidy our industry
doesn't look for handouts people are are
self-reliant they're independent
entrepreneurs um and they help the local
economy in a in a huge way they're part
of the web so we're we're not looking
for handouts and I think it's
disparaging to use the word subsidy when
this is in fact a credit that is earned
by the biomass plants I'm I'm not as uh
up on the thermal part of it um other
than I know that there's local like
schools and and um the County Farms that
have invested millions of dollars into
into building small biomass plants um to
to produce renewable energy once again
and this all ties into the forest
industry
yeah yeah thank you okay thank you for
that uh that answer before I call on the
next questioner for Mr Marino I would
like to ask a question of Representative
Harrington representative Harrington I
was reading your amendment to HB
213 and it says on line five that it
amends the bill by replacing all after
the enacting Clause with the following
and then it essentially
repes
thees of the original
Bill and then it it excuse me Mr
chairman can you give me a second I got
to get a copy of the bill I
locations I'm going to thank
representative bares me for uh noticing
what appears to be a discrepancy here
but I just wanted to
verify that it is a discrepancy and not
your
intention with this
am while we're while we're waiting Mr Mr
chair it appears there's two Sor about
the delay back hands up in the attendees
list to speak I think
okay thank you uh okay are you ready to
answer a question yes yes I am I have
the amendment in front of me now so the
amendment says in line five amend the
bill by replacing all after the enacting
Clause with the
F does that it this amendment replaces
the entire Bill no that's I'm sorry that
was a mistake I don't know that was a
miscommunication between uh legislative
services and myself
the only thing that should have been
changed is the wording on lines 10 and
11 so I'll have to go back to them and
get that fixed that was not the intent
of the bill it was simply to grandfather
in the thermal energy that's being used
for Rex prior to January 1st 2020 it was
not to replace the entire Bill thank you
for catching that it was a mistake on my
part thank representative Bry for
catching that mistake okay thank you you
will be getting a new Amendment then
yeah I'll go right back to him and let
him know oops uh oh people can you still
hear me because you just disappeared yes
we can still hear okay all right I can't
see you anymore I don't know what's
going on here anyways if you can still
hear me yeah I'll go back to legislative
services this afternoon and get that
fixed okay great thank you for
clarifying that uh now I'll call on
recognize representative samich for a
question uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Mr
Moreno um how to make this I don't know
if you're the right person to ask this
but you probably can answer it um my
understanding was that the biomass
plants in general uh not only do they
produce energy and so forth but the the
byproduct after the combustion is wood
ash which has become a pro commodity for
the agricultural industry is that
correct
know um representative ssuch do you have
a question specific to the
bill yes thank you uh Mr Sage can you
hear me this this question goes right to
the fact that this bill threatens that
industry and that industry provides not
only the the wood product but also
provides a secondary market for the
waste
so that doesn't seem relevant to the
purpose of the bill uh producers of Ash
don't get any renewable energy credits
do
they well well no but but if but if the
industry is shut down they won't have a
product to sell so we have two other
people who would like to speak so if we
could try to confine our questions to
the bill itself to help us understand
whether the bill is uh appropriate or
not that would be very helpful rather
than having long and rambling
discussions about the forest industry
let's talk specifically about how the
bill uh will affect directly affect the
forest Product
Industry well I'll withdraw my question
Mr chairman thank
you representative resent is recognized
for a question thank you Mr chairman and
thank you uh Mr Morana for your
testimony uh my question is what are the
inefficiencies that prevent biomass
plants from operating without the
subsidy I'm not able to answer that
question thank you okay thank you seeing
no other questions for Mr Mareno I will
now call
on meline Mano Miss Mano you have two
minutes thank you chairman Vose and
members of the committee for the
opportunity to speak on this bill our
renewable portfolio standard is a very
important and the only policy to promote
local renewable energy and fuel
diversity fuel diversity helps to
protect customers against price
volatility and increases resilience our
current goals in the RPS is to get 25%
renewable energy by
2025 HB 213 would reduce our goal for
new Renewables by half affecting class
one electric class one thermal class two
solar and class three biomass Electric
other states are ramping up their RPS
goals and that's attracting investment
and employment to their state to our
detriment it would be a mistake to lower
our goals now I want to speak to um the
class two solar goals since that hasn't
been mentioned by other testimony before
HB 213 would lower the goals back down
to
0.3% that's completely unnecessary we
already have about 0.8% of our
electricity coming from solar sources so
there's already an overabundance of Rex
in the market you've also heard from the
Pu that there's a Rec sweeping free
credit of
0.4% that would be bigger than the goal
if HB 213
passed even with the amendment we would
still oppose HB
um when you are paying your heating oil
or propane Bill only about 22% of that
is going to our direct local economy
when biomass fuels are purchased 90% of
that spending goes directly to
benefiting our local economy you've
heard from many local government schools
businesses that have invested in
efficient wood pellet heating systems
the benefits that has that that has had
for both them and our forest products
industry we ask that you not take that
opportunity away from others to also
have those same benefits thank you and
I'm happy to take
questions thank you Miss Mano any
questions from Miss
know seeing
none there is one more hand rais but I'm
reluctant
to allow the person to speak because
they are listed on my screen is having a
name of Moto
G parentheses 7 Clos parentheses
play that doesn't that worries that's
just a phone I know that individual
that's a Bonafide
address how do I know
that I I've been in communication with I
can't think of the person's name off the
top of my head but I recognize the
address I'm vouching For The
Individual we have to know the name to
be the name of a device and not a person
so I'm not going to recognize uh the
same thing as a phone number those are
also if the person wants to relog in as
themselves then I'll allow don't have a
way to do that logging in as a device is
not appropriate in this setting so with
that we can close finally the public
hearing on HB
213 and I thank you all for
participating and now we can
open the public hearing on HB or
actually resume the public hearing on HB
and we will do so
now and I will speak
first and introduce an amend
representative
V uh yes you have a question yes please
I never got the amendment I called this
morning and asked for it to be forwarded
to
me and I don't have it is it possible
that you could forward me the amendment
to my email address well when I sent the
amendment to the committee on right and
and I didn't get it yesterday and I made
a phone call this
morning and asked for it to be forwarded
to me sent to
me uh and it hasn't been sent so is
there any way you can send that to me as
I was about to say before you
interrupted me uh on Saturday afternoon
when I sent the amendment to the
committee I also sent it
to uh your personal email
address as I have it is your a is your
uh
address jacen CIP pittz nope at
AOL.com it's
c917
aol.com okay so
you there are multiple email addresses
out there for you then h i don't have
multiple I have only had one for about
30 years maybe
more is it possible for somebody to send
that to me or for you to send it to me
or Gent to send it to me I will send it
right now what is what is your email
again c a l
i
aol.com
[Music]
917 my birthday
thank
you okay I have just sent it to you uh
would you please let me know if you
receive shouldn't take too
long well in the meantime you can let us
know uh if and when you receive it
representative C pitz in the meantime
I'm going to go ahead and
introduce the amendment which is
amendment number
202-
[Music]
04578 I sent a PDF of this amendment to
all of the addresses I have that are
assigned to the house Science and
Technology
group that's part of the house email
system so let me describe very briefly
just what this amendment
does the major major changes in the
amendment are number one the amendment
uses language provided by The Honorable
Clifton voo in both section six of the
amendment and uh on line six and in most
of section
it also adds a purchase of receivables
provision that is optional not
mandatory as requested by
Liberty and it also adds a restriction
on the imposition of exit fees in
section six as suggested by Mark Brown
of the consumer energy
Alliance so if you have any specific
questions about the amendment I will try
to answer them I will tell you that the
next person I'm going to recognize is
Clifton Belo The Honorable Clifton Belo
and he will have some comments about
the
amendment in addition to Mr Belo we
have six people who have signed up to
testify on the bill and uh hopefully
they will testify on the amendment not
the bill as original Ally written so
with that I'll recognize anyone on the
committee who wants to ask a question
about the
amendment well seeing none I guess we'll
go right
to CFT and
Belo and Mr V you are recognized to
speak on the
amendment thank you Mr chairman I I was
having a hard time getting my U unmuting
to stick um I I appreciate last week I
reached out to Chairman Vos um as well
as more recently uh to eversource um and
you know offered that I I would like to
help try to contribute to some
compromise here um I appreciate the fact
that he has um Incorporated uh some of
the suggested amendments uh that I uh
put forth in in my testimony um just to
clarify though I I haven't contributed
any of the language on um the revised
section six of the bill at this point um
and um and I and I still have some
questions about that but uh I I
appreciate that you know apparently
eversource's willingness to um
accommodate a couple of the suggested
amendments um is is a significant
movement on their part um I still have a
number of issues with the bill um as I
do think other parties that I've been in
conversation with about it um a lot of
those are in the other sections of the
bill that this amendment does not
address sections one through five and
seven of the bill um and so I do hope um
that that we'll be able to continue to
work to find a common ground because
because I think there's been a fair
amount of Mis misunderstanding about uh
some what's going on both in both in the
law and at the Pu
uh the you know if part of the goal is
to Simply enable uh and to limit uh
Community power aggregation uh to the
Massachusetts model it's important to
note that the bill you know if it was
passed with this amendment would not
even do that uh there's still a couple
of significant problems even to do the
basic Massachusetts model uh and and
there's also significant Authority that
Massachusetts Municipal aggregators have
that would uh be curtailed in in this uh
um Bill overall um one of those is that
um uh everyone has recognized that to do
a customer enrollment on an opt out
basis the aggregator has to have um uh
the account numbers uh of the um default
service customers um this bill U does
not provide for that and it strikes from
the statute in a different section of
the bill that's not seen in the
amendment um the language that gave the
Pu authority to do that as acknowledged
by eversource's own attorney uh so you
know with with a part of the bill that's
not referenced here uh combined with
what's in the in the new text um there's
there's a pretty strong argument which
eversource attorney made that the
commission neither the commission nor
the aggregators have any Authority uh to
obtain the account numbers to do
enrollment on an opt-out basis so so
that is different than Massachusetts um
there's also um I think the the the
chairman tried to um address the issue
of incremental cost I I agree that that
language could or incidental costs I
agree that language could uh use some
additional clarification I've suggested
some but it's not reflected here um
there you know what it does is strike
the reference to in zental cost uh you
know to comply with the provisions of
the statute being allowable the notion
of incidental cost has been in the law
for 25 years no other state has such a
restriction um although I agree that we
do not want a regular taxpayer
subsidizing this kind of program once
it's up and running um however the
language about increment incremental
cost associated with the establishment
of such a program could include
something as simple as having a
community's um Town Council review the
propos warrant article for the town
meeting to consider adoption of an
aggregation plan um or to review the
aggregation plan itself or even at a
city council meeting where we discuss
the matter we pay our recording
secretary by the hour so if we spend an
hour discussing an aggregation plan is
that an incremental cost associated with
establishing the program it's I just
think it it you know we had that problem
when we with my city manager we began to
look at this and there was just a
discomfort in spending anything
including half time on this with with
with such a broad uh prohibition so I
think that still needs clarification um
more significantly though the bill does
um uh really shut off a lot of
opportunities for uh aggregate uh for
for um Innovative new markets uh that
could harness the power of competitive
markets and just real quickly sort of
Economics 101 is the notion that supply
and demand need to see similar price
signals in order to optimize price
formation we have a wholesale Market in
which there is a very strong temporal
aspect to the value of electricity we
have a retail Market that does not
translate those in order to do that you
need interval metering and um and and
the the current law simply allows with
the Pu approving it in an adjudicated
proceeding uh for there to be a method
for an aggregation to potentially
contribute uh to the cost uh to upgrade
such interval metering and it's it's
it's I just want to say if you haven't
had a chance to look at Professor em
Freed's testimony I would urge you to do
so sort of buried in his long document
is the fact that the city of Lebanon
Liberty Utilities the fair School of
Engineering at Dartmouth the tux School
of Business at Dartmouth the Cary uh
school for public policy at un and a
faculty from MIT including the
co-director of their center for the
integration of complex uh Engineering
Systems are applying for $2.5 million
National Science Foundation smart and
connected communities Grant to further
develop an existing collaboration with
Liberty on um uh uh developing
transactive energy which is simply the
concept of linking Supply and the demand
in the electricity system uh through the
response of electric loads and
generation on the customer side of the
meter to price signals it's it's just a
basic thing that can improve the
economic efficiency of what we're doing
I'm kind of over the time uh so I'm
going to stop there but I I hope to
continue working with the sponsor and
other interested stakeholders to figure
out language that can actually make this
work um for all of us thank
you thank you uh Mr V can you tell us
specifically where in either the
amendment or the original
bill that new lead new languages need
needed in order to
enable the kinds of things you were just
talking about um with regard to the
development of uh a new paradigm for
connecting consumers and uh providers of
electricity well just for starters um
the um bill in a section that's
unamended would strike the authority uh
for an aggregation to provide demand
side man management out outside of the
utility or is on New England programs
and that's a specific example that we
want to continue and develop in our
pilot which is uh we worked with a um an
a broker Freedom energy Logistics uh to
curtail our load at the uh times that
were projected to be a coincident Peak
demand so that we could uh reduce
dramatically reduce our capacity tag uh
for the forward capacity Market that's
not a utility or is a New England
program it's the kind of um thing that
transactive energy value would provide
um help customers to take something as
simple as their hot water heater and
move it off um off peak um just just
another example of something that might
be problematic is um we we worked the
city worked with I uh Liberty to develop
their um battery pilot the battery pilot
has um both them supplying batteries and
also um a bring your own battery option
that hasn't really quite begun yet well
we would like to maybe um work with that
situation but the but the new language
in the bill um talks about um even an
opt-in program um being not allowed to
have any exit uh fees well Liberty in
their battery program because they're
financing the cost of the battery has an
exit fee if somebody terminates the
contract early uh they have to pay for
having the battery removed and perhaps
some other cost but this bill would say
we could not do the same thing with a
bring your own battery program uh just
as one example um there there are more
that I could go into um I can do that
now if you'd like um but but those are
illustrative of of the problems I think
um well I appreciate that and maybe
those examples are illustrative
what was not illustrative was a specific
reference to a line in the
bill or the amendment that you find
objectional okay well the specific um
more guidance on on what what language
you specifically have problems with yes
on page one um line 13 of the bill um it
changes the law that just simply says we
could provide demand site Management
Services to say through utility or
Regional system operator administered
management programs and you know just a
rule of statutory construction if
something said you could do demand side
management before but now it's changed
and says through these two things by
implication uh you can't do it outside
of those two activities so you know I
think we would lose our authority to do
that outside of those programs same
thing with conservation um the same
thing with with meter reading the meter
reading even in the proposed rules can
only be effectuated in cooperation with
utility and by approval of the Pu but
that would be part of our uh pilot that
we want to work out with liberty and
Liberty is indicated that they're
willing to work out with us to figure
out how we can do that um so so that's
you know there there's three of them
right there in section three of the bill
that are problematic um um
to be specific okay thank you I
appreciate that specificity it helps uh
understand helps us understand how we
could make changes to the bill that
could be
acceptable provided of course that other
parties are are agreeable to
it are there any other specific examples
well yes in section one of the bill at
line three striking the word provide um
it now says we could only broker or
contract for those services our thought
for our limited pilot you know for 25
maybe 25 or 50 customers including a
number of City accounts um was that it
might be easiest to do that if we
ourselves with the load serving entity
because for the sort of mass Market
product the um the opt out product that
would be based on a fixed price there's
no no variable pricing there that the
customers would know in advance so this
would be an opin opt
um and the thought was you know a load
serving entity creates its own meter
domain each one so for instance the town
of Handover is its own load serving
entity and all the municipal meters are
under their load serving domain um and
uh that way we could take the um uh
real-time pricing product or dead
pricing product from ISO no England that
were're build and uh use use that uh as
a vehicle to do that with uh
other customers that are in the pilot um
so striking the language about provide
there is problematic it's also
problematic uh elsewhere in the bill
where um it it removes language about um
allowing a uh aggregation to be a load
serving entity now now I I just want to
say that I think the vast majority of
communities this is not where anybody's
going to start um uh you know th this is
perhaps very limited in its initial
steps um and it's more of a pilot and
we'd have to prove you know prove the
concept that this is actually something
that can work uh but but um we we think
it's worth doing and don't see why you
know we we reference in this uh Grant
application the fact that um this the
existing law gives us the authorities to
be able to do this and that kind of you
know would likely go away um uh with
without further accommodation in terms
of what the law provides
okay so I appreciate that um specific
information it sounds to me like it
might be useful for us to get together a
group of interested parties get together
in a room and sit down and go line by
line through the existing law and
propose changes to it to see what we can
agree on uh jointly usually in those
kinds of sessions nobody gets everything
they want there's parts of the bill that
everybody hates but um it's something
that everybody can lo is that something
that you'd be willing to participate in
I would certainly uh make a full full
effort to do such um and make the time
to do that over the next two
weeks okay thank you I'll now the chair
will now recognize representative McGee
for a question thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Mr Belo for taking my question
um one of the things that has struck me
over the life of our looking at um HB
315 is we've received a lot of different
um we've received amendments but we've
also received documents trying to uh
Chronicle the difference that's going on
in what 53e was and what it is now and
it's very difficult to figure out the
changes and I think you mentioned this
in your testimony so that's what I'm
leading to is it appears that in the
amendment there are a number of areas of
53e that are omitted so that you can't
actually read through it and figure out
which things are being lost and which
things are being edited and which things
would remain as they are so I think from
my perspective it's very hard for me to
follow the changes one of those examples
I I noted was in I think it's section
three under regulation of aggregators
under RSA
53e um there's a question of whether an
aggregator will be considered a public
utility or not and so there's there's
some very sort of important changes and
to Chairman Bose's point we really need
to be able to go through the through the
sections of what we're proposing to
change so that we know what we're voting
for um because it seems like some of
these could be extremely significant to
how things operate in the real world and
I just wondered if you could comment on
that because you seem to be you know
intimately familiar with the original uh
RSA and and the changes you've been
following the changes as they've been
going well yes and that's why I provided
as a tachman a in my um testimony uh
that kind of U detail you know I I went
through and um because many sections of
the the bill are repeal and replace it's
not obvious how they changed the law and
when I first read through the bill
several parts I thought well that's not
too bad but then when I actually looked
at how it changed the statute I said
that's very problematic so um you know
as it progresses I'd be happy to do the
same you know one of the attachments to
my testimony actually went back to two
years ago where I did the same thing and
showed how the bill and I provided that
back um in the Senate as well as in the
house and provided it to all the
utilities and the Pu and other
stakeholders uh so so people could you
know see it all in detail and I I I I
find that to be very helpful
thank you representative oxenham is
recognized for a
question thank you very much Mr chair um
I I think we can all agree that this
bill is not ready for prime time I we
have um objections from the municipal
Association from Mayors from energy
committees from businesses saying that
this is going to interfere with um
projected investment plans uh interfere
with efforts to achieve ready for 100
commitments that towns have made to
their constituents um I I don't see the
point in you know we've been told again
and again we have to hurry up we can't
ask questions we have to move along and
and you this this seems to me to be an
inappropriate use of the time of this
body if we're running up against
deadlines the bill is is not ready to
proceed and and we should move on is
there a question
there no so that was addressed to the
chair I think that this is a misuse of
time I was reprimanded at the end of the
last session for wasting people's time I
I I don't understand how this particular
Bill maybe it's because who the sponsor
is the the time limits no longer seem to
matter well I apologize representative
if we're wasting your time but we're
obligated to follow the rules of the
house we started a public hearing and we
have to finish the public hearing and we
have one two three four five may I ask
that we move along rather than go
through this line by
line this is not an appropriate use of
the committee's time this should be done
in a work
session representative oxam you keep
interrupting and you really
are gonna have to seriously consider
changing your behavior you're disrupting
the process to the point where it's
getting very very difficult to get
anything
done um
I object to your comment because I could
object to a lot of behaviors I've seen
here so I think you're
being uh I don't want to be interrupted
until I finish my point I will recognize
you representative ssuch to speak once I
have concluded what I have to say and
I'm not going to allow you to interrupt
me while I'm
speaking the point I was trying to make
representative oxim is we have rules of
decorum in the committee and you seem to
flout them Time After Time After Time I
have discussed this with you an email
you even apologized to me and
acknowledged that you were in violation
of our code of decorum and yet you keep
doing it over and over and over I'm
reluctant to speak to the speaker of the
house about you and your behavior but if
you continue I I don't see how I have
any other choice but to do that so
please think about what you're doing and
try to follow our rules of
dor representative samset you're now
recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman but as a
point of order I'd first like to make
the comment I think that you are being
very biased and one-sided here about
such things and it may be a little bit
too delicate but let me ask a question
of Mr Belo um we all kind of have seen
from the testimony that this is a very
complicated Bill and even the changes
that have been proposed are very
detailed and very complicated so my
question to Mr Belo is in light of the
fact that this bill was only signed in
2019 by the governor and the rules have
not yet been finalized by the Pu why do
we even need to change it before we can
see how it's implemented
well I I I think there are a couple of
things and the the amendment does
address those uh that there is a broader
consensus that that should be changed
just to avoid unnecessary cost for the
utilities to change their U software and
business processes it doesn't really
affect uh um the the effectiveness or
what Municipal aggregators could do it's
just um um an issue that would be easier
fixed in the statute than in rules and
and I say that because I you know tried
to draft Draft rules that work around
the constraint of the statute and and
nobody was really happy with that um uh
so I think you know there is a piece of
this that's easier change through
statute um there there is a Senate bill
that uh uh addresses that very issue
that that is part of one of the
Amendments that was incorporated in uh
to Chairman vos's um proposed amendment
um uh
and and I know that something that that
is um you know the main issue that
Liberty originally was approached on
about the bill and and they agreed it
should be changed I agree that could be
changed so so I mean my preference is to
sort of narrow the scope to the things
that really need to be addressed but I
but I I hear ever Source saying that
they feel like there's more than just
that issue that needs to be addressed
and I'm happy to engage in that direct
dialogue with them and and see if we can
get to yes over the next two weeks um
you know I think it'd be better if we if
we can clean this up this year than but
but but if it can't be you know I would
hope the consider committee would
consider retaining the bill and look at
what comes over from the Senate as a
possible um interm solution where where
there you know there could be time to
look at all the other issues um but but
you're right it hasn't even nobody's
actually started a a municipal
aggregation yet there's a lot of
interest in it I think a lot of the
interest is on the potential of how this
could develop over time and and we
really see this as an ability to have
our local communities partner with the
distribution utilities um because we all
know that there's fairly dramatic
improvements that could be done to the
electric grid in terms of the E
efficiency of how it operates that's
what a lot of the grid modernization
discussion has been about the
development of time of use rates what we
need to do to accommodate EV charging uh
without you know pushing that all on
Peak demand uh so so there's a whole
bunch of interconnected issues and I
think that over time
communities could be better partners
with utilities and it would help you
know part of the vision of this is that
if you're a municipal aggregation and
you're providing load following service
local people are going to need to learn
more about what that really means you
can't just rely on solar um like we do
in net metering you know it produces in
the summer you use it in the winter well
you that only works if you actually have
storage that can last that long uh in
terms of load following service so I'm
kind of getting off point here but but
um you know yes um it's it's complex uh
but the system is complex and I think
the more there is community engagement
in understanding how it works and
working with the distribution Utilities
in constructive ways the better off
we're going to be thank
you you need a follow
up thank you Mr
chairman thank
you representative oxim you have your
hand up you have a serious
question I'll
pass thank you I seeing no more
questions for Mr voo I will turn to our
next
speaker and I will allow Mr Cliff
Lazenby to speak Mr
Len represent the Portsmouth City
Council sustainab sustain ility
committee Mr Len be you recognized for
two minutes yes thank you um so my name
is Cliff lby thank you chairman and
members of the of the committee I am a
city councel in Portsmouth and I do
serve on our uh
sustainability committee though today I
speak simply as a SE Coast resident and
I am speaking in opposition to HB 315 um
I don't officially represent the views
of the council or our our our committee
because we have not yet had the chance
to fully review the legislation however
you do also have a letter signed by our
mayor in opposition to the bill um the
sustainability committee on which I
serve has been working since last year
to review opportunities for Portsmith
related to community power at our
meeting last month we were getting ready
for a work session uh to present uh for
the city council to formalize pursuit of
a community power program and think
about other Coalition opportunities in
this regard we're concerned that hb3 315
will hamper the pursuit of community
power for the benefit of our
municipality and taxpayers it greatly
limits or eliminates local control and
Community customer choice for
competitive electricity services it
would hurt our ability to Source
electricity from local Renewables like
solar power uh there was some question
earlier in the public hearing last week
regarding um uh public discussions I do
definitely want to share there a
significant interest in Portsmouth for
Community aggregation and Community
power
and finally I did want to express
agreement with a comment from uh
representative ssuch during the February
12th hearing uh regarding confidence in
the opportunity to choose alternative
suppliers with our municipality
reviewing Community power opportunities
we can increase the likelihood of our
residents being comfortable to enjoy the
advantages of competition to Source less
expensive power Andor power sourced from
Renewables beyond that we we hope to
work with our local representatives to
discuss further thank you for
letting me share My
Views you very much we appreciate it any
questions for Mr L representative Samson
should recognize for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you U Mr glenby for coming to testify um
my my impression from your comments was
that uh you you and uh your group in
Portsmith apparently see the current law
as it is right now now as offering you
all the opportunities you would like to
use um without it having to be changed
so um is is that kind of is that
impression correct that you think the
law as it is right now for you and your
your efforts are is already in place the
way you'd like that to
be yes I I I I think that would be
accurate to be clear you know we are
we're not as far along as some of the um
New Hampshire communities in pursuing
this so we've been looking at this for
the last few months um we see the
opportunities we're seeing examples set
by you know other cities like Lebanon
and and NASA um and and see a great deal
of opportunity beyond that you know as
it as it is sort of a complicated
subject we are relying on numerous other
people who spend more time with it uh
the new Municipal Association is one of
those groups that you know we definitely
rely on their input um and others um
even the testimony you've received from
others um who are further along so you
know whether it was fully baked I can't
really comment on in terms of the the
existing legislation we certainly saw
the opportunity and we um would uh we
would hate to lose that opportunity I
think would would really be it and if if
this new legislation even as amended um
would would hamper that Pursuit uh that
would be a
concern thank you very much
representative Cali pittz is recognized
for a
question I didn't forget I'm just slow
on the trigger Council Len um do you
realize that the rules have not even
been promulgated yet
to allow this to happen and that it will
probably be at least another all 18
months or so before anything like this
can happen and we do have time or do you
think we have time to make this uh Bill
better I I can't comment exactly on the
those time frames you know in terms of
the rules or the 18 months um I guess
what would be very beneficial to us and
and I've uh we we invited you and
representative ssuch uh to come speak
with our first our sustainability
committee we would be very interested to
learn we we'd be it'd be great to learn
more about the opportunity and then
specifically uh representative Kelly
Pitts I know you're a sponsor it would
be great to learn um why you think this
legislation amended or not would help
that so that would be a help to us that
invitation is there we're meeting this
week or another time I Haven cff I
haven't received any
invitation uh I say I well we can go
over it offline be happy to we can go
over it offline yeah I email that you
late last week but so yeah we we we hope
to learn more because we we see the the
opportunity and the need is there and so
the best way to have the legislation
reflect that um uh we're certainly open
to that learn more thank
you thank you uh representative C pitz I
probably shouldn't have recognized you
since you're a for sponsor
representative McGee is I can ask I
didn't present
though representative o mattered in the
past yes you can ask you may you you can
ask a question if you don't present
correct I thought the rule was that if
you're a co-sponsor of the bill you
can't answer questions but I'll get a
verification of that thank you
representative migy you're recognized
for a question yes thank you Mr chair
it's actually a point of order about the
folks who are waiting in the participant
list with their hands up um somebody
sent me a text and said that these folks
were signed up to speak in the last
hearing and the time ran out so they're
wondering whether they'll actually be
acknowledged even though we may not have
that list of people who were signed up
it may be you know they didn't get to
sign up because the link wasn't working
today so I guess they're just curious as
to whether their last sign up is okay
which I don't blame them because they're
they're here again trying to you know
say what they want to say yes okay if
before I answer that question could I
just ask people to ask succinct
questions rather
than going on and on and on and dragging
out a question so that I forget what
it's about before I even get to the end
so the answer to your question
representative McGee is I will allow
everyone who has asked to speak to speak
even if we're here until five o'clock
thank
you okay see no one else
uh wanting to ask a question
of Mr lenb we now turn to the next
speaker on the list and that would
be
Rebecca
wednes yes Rebecca doesn't want to speak
so we'll allow Andrea Hodson to speak
Miss Austin hod Hodson you have two
minutes
thank
you uh I'm I'm a member of the
Harrisville select board and the
electric aggregation committee and uh
like Portsmith Harrisville is interested
in community power though we may be
further along in processing the
opportunities and developing our
community power plan for a town meeting
vote this year we are a small town
according to eversource in July we had
roughly 950 15 rate payers and we had
consumed roughly
4,175 megawatts of electricity Supply in
a 12-month lookback period so it was
incumbent on our committee to evaluate
RSA 53e to know whether the community
power could be even feasible or in the
best interest of a town our size to
adopt and
240 citizen volunteer hours later
we realized that Community power is
grounded in our master plan and with the
support and input of many of the
residents who got involved our work
resulted in a community power warrant
article to be presented at town meeting
we assumed that if the town votes to
authorize Community power pu will have
done its job of rul making to support
our sucessful
implementation we did not anticipate new
legislation that would effectively
reverse and abandon the local control
and opportunities promised by RSA 53e 32
we respectfully urge you support our
Endeavor to implement Community power
and not HB 315 thank
you thank you we appreciate your
testimony I especially appreciated your
written testimony and your inclusion of
the Harrisville Community power
project plan I actually read the plan
and the first thing that struck me about
it was that it
contains items or materials that make me
believe that it would be impossible for
the plan to
provide electricity to the residents of
Harrisville at an affordable rate and I
discussed it with a couple of other
people and they agreed with that
assessment
I would also point out to you that um if
you plan to go to town meeting this year
rulle making probably won't be done for
at least a year
so I don't know if
your taxpayers want to adopt the plan
that may not be implementable for a year
or two down the road something for you
to consider uh are there any other
questions for um M
Hodson seeing none we will go to our
next speaker who is
Samuel Golding Mr Golding you have two
minutes thank you I'm a resident of
conquer and a political Economist and
consultant who spent a decade focused on
community power Market Development I've
been advising the community power
Coalition of New Hampshire since late
2019 and I
previously testimony to this committee
the scope of changes uh proposed
violates basic Market design principles
and would harm the public
interest I appreciate how the testimony
submitted in support took care to
explain some of the thinking behind the
bill but it's it's the logic and the
reasons stated are actually Incorrect
and I'd like to address several here the
first is that this bill is necessary to
fix major issues preventing the
commission from adopting rules that's
simply not true there's minor refin make
but no disagreements in the workshop shs
commission staff are on record saying as
much and that rules would be adopted in
a matter of
weeks before this C and kind of derailed
that process supporters apparently
believe that the management of wholesale
supply and the management and Retail
consumption are somehow unrelated and
that attempting to do both is a source
of risk for communities and that's why
they say they want to limit the New
Hampshire aggregators to only focusing
on wholesale take away all the ret
demand authorities metering billing
programs and they think the
Massachusetts model should be emulated
as a first step in that regard well in
Massachusetts Municipal aggregators
actually receive individual customer
account data and usage prior to launch
they can pay for Interval meters and
communication upgrades they can SE send
separate Supply bills for example for
large customers very convenient and for
Mass market utility Consolidated billing
which is already covered by purchase of
receivables there
they can actually request different rate
structures to be programmed into the
Utility Billing System they also
efficiency programs and programs so
whether or not that's happening in
Massachusetts well anyway is really a
question of the market structure the
second is that um you know seconds as
vice mayor Cliff Belo
explained worked with freedom to put
their real-time pricing product and drop
their usage at the right time to save
money that's supply and demand that's
retail and wholesale that's the sort of
innovation we want to see and removing
those authorities from Community power
aggregators is anti- competitive and has
no public policy basis or Market design
basis okay we appreciate your
testimony representative ssuch is
recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr Golding for
testifying um and please let me know if
I understood your your your testimony
corly it seems to me that you're saying
that in your
opinion uh the current law that was
signed in
2019 is adequate to be made to work as
intended and doesn't really need many
changes at this
point my impression is that the
commission has the requisite authority
to fill in the gaps and uh we were
anticipating a draft set of rules that
would do that on key issues um which
would then and then an adjudicative
proceeding to finalize the
rules okay thank you as Cliff mentioned
there are areas that the legislature
could clarify but oh okay thank you we
appreciate your testimony Mr Goldie I'll
now recognize the next speaker who
is Robert Hayden Mr Hayden you have two
minutes thank you representative Bose
and thank you everybody there for your
service um standard power works with 60
communities here in New Hampshire
already for their electricity needs and
we've partnered with good a uh good
energy to implement Community power we
have a contract with Keen already to
implement uh Community power and we're
well along the way in the process to do
that based on the fact
that we expected the Pu to have the
rules uh made that have been discussed
by several other
speakers with the Advent of HB
315 the ability to implement for Keen
has been surely interrupted or slowed
down we were at a point where we have
already had public Outreach to the
community we've provided a sample of a
plan to the community that they would be
voting on and they are
essentially prior to HB 315 we're ready
to launch some of the things with HB 315
that we find positive are the fact that
it addresses the P issue very important
to maintain a high level of supplier
participation and in addition um the
ability to collect new client data after
the launch is positive
but on the other side of the coin
there's a variety of issues with the
bill that make it quite
onor uh the utility under the bill as we
know it as I haven't read the amendment
I haven't had that luxury and I would
love to be able to comment again on this
matter of fact if there's a committee
that does any work on this I would like
to be part of it as standard power has a
contract with one of our communities
already um the cost issue about having
no incidental cost be borne by the
community is rather difficult it all
pretty much elates any participation by
the community and Hayden we appreciate
your participation and your testimony
here this morning well I appreciate
you're allowing me to talk and I I have
been part of all of the Pu meetings and
we've been part of implementing a
program that exists so please have us in
whatever further rul making you do
please send us uh your email an email
that uh indicates your willingness to
participate in a discussion about this
yes sir thank you very much for that
opportunity thank
you okay next on the uh agenda are there
any
questions oh there is a question I'm
sorry oh thank you so much sir see
representative McGee's hand until just
now representative McGee you're
recognized for a question which I hope
won't be a rambling one but a six
chairman I'm sorry that I'm who I am um
Mr Hayden you mentioned uh that the no
incidental cost was one of the things
that you thought was problematic I was
sort of writing down your problematic
not problem did you have other items you
could give us quickly that you feel are
problematic so that we have that
information well I think all of the
constrictions on future Innovation are
IM impossible to deal with really it's
that there's so many wonderful things
that the bill as written the law as
written you know 53e could do for our
communities in their opportunity to
reduce costs while increasing the
proliferation of Renewable Power in
their portfolio that leads to the goals
of communities like Keen who have a 100%
goal conquered and other communities
also have the these 100% goals that lead
to a cleaner Greener future that
supports not only the New Hampshire
economy but the ecology the education
and
jobs thank you for the question and I'm
looking forward to the next
[Music]
question representative ssuch is
recognized for a question yes uh thank
you Mr chairman and thank you Mr Hayden
for taking the my my question uh my
question to you is would you character
um this bill HB 315 as anti- Innovative
and
anti-competitive uh that's a great
question Peter I really appreciate it um
I I think that as
written it is anti- innovation there's a
surely a future where the utilities will
have the opportunity to monetize the
two-way flow of energy from Storage to
generation to usage and to the um
virtual battery that all of our storage
at home and our cars and our power walls
will create that future is a future
that's on the way and it'll sweep ac
across the country as we will see in the
near future so the ability to be on
track with those things is incredibly
important to not only New Hampshire but
all of New England across the New
England ISO
thank you representative crean is
recognized for a question thank you
chairman and uh thank you Mr Hayden for
taking my question um in your testimony
you mentioned appreciating that the bill
resolves the P issue can you just um
speak a little bit more to that what
that issue was and and how the bill
resolves it uh thank you very much for
the question and thank you for your time
and service I have had not had the
pleasure of meeting with you yet but I
do look forward to working with you in
the future um I think that the
PO language is incredibly important and
if we have the pleasure of um dropping
this bill we would strongly encourage it
be moved to
sb91 section
3 um but as it is now without po which
is a mechanism by way that the utility
purchases uh folks who are way behind on
their bills they purchase that
receivable account and pay the supplier
or the entity a discounted value for it
so right now um a supplier is in a very
bad position to collect um back
debt and with po they would receive that
discounted value for all bad debt that
way suppliers would be more likely to
participate in this program one of the
primary suppliers in New Hampshire is a
company called constellation and it
appears as though the only reason
they're choosing not to participate at
this time is the lack of P which much of
the country who's implemented um
Community power programs has included in
their law
language
next you have representative cran nope
I'm all that thank you very much
okay she's all set and so are we so
thank you Mr Hayden we look forward to
uh working with you on this
uh on this legislation thank you
representative Vose and thank you for
your
time next I'll call on uh Jennifer Smith
Miss Smith you have two
minutes okay thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee um I first want
to note that I was signed up to speak on
the previous bill but I had to sign back
out and sign back in by the time I
signed back in you had closed the
hearing um I think you know it would
have been simple enough to unmute me and
ask who I was but in any case I I would
have appreciated talking on that bill
this bill I am a member of energy
Committee in Penbrook New Hampshire um I
don't know that we're ready to begin
thinking about this but I'm distressed
to think that a bill like this will in
fact delay the Pu issuing rules which I
was waiting on to see before I started
talking to other members of our energy
committee and to the town select board
about this um opportunity we do have a
um pilot agreement with a so commercial
solar um going in in the near future and
it would be a wonderful opportunity to
um add value kind of value stacking sort
of thing um so I would appreciate it if
this bill was just retained um and you
work with the Senate energy committee to
do any fixes that Mr Bel and others can
agree to and not spend a lot of time on
this Bill thank
you thank you are there any questions
from Miss
Smith representative Cali pittz I don't
think I'm allowed to let you ask
questions oh okay haven't gotten
clarification on that yet we're still
working on it all
right anybody else have a question from
Miss
Smith see none
I will now call on Rebecca no last name
given Rebecca you have the floor for two
minutes thank you very much uh chairman
my name is Rebecca McKenzie and I'm a
member of the energy advisory committee
in Claremont New
Hampshire I agree with claremont's mayor
Charlene LoveIt who publicly opposed HB
315 I am here to respectfully
request that you vote inexpedient to
legislate on HB 315 for many of the
reasons that have already been stated I
attended the first hearing was surprised
to hear that some say that Community
power and Community aggregation are two
different things it is my understanding
that Community power and Community
aggregation are the same I hope that
this important issue continues to be
clarified
the reason Claremont continues to
research Community power is because we
would like the option to choose the most
economically available electric power
source the option to choose from a
variety of renewable energy
sources be able to transition to
community power without having to
reinvent a customer base that would make
it
viable and the opportunity to build more
self-reliance with local power
generation Claremont businesses
nonprofits and the municipality continue
to invest in local renewable energy and
HB 3155 undermines all these options and
forces New Hampshire to settle for the
inadequate model of community power also
known as the mass Massachusetts
model we are looking for looking into
Community power options that would
increase our competitive buying power
collaborating with many other New
Hampshire municipalities to reduce the
cost of electricity as well as other
options that Community power provides
our energy advisory committee recently
took an energy resilience prod project
as part of our portfolio of work for the
upcoming foreseeable future we
appreciate your testimony thank you for
being here any questions for Rebecca
representative Harrington it's
recognized for a question yeah thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question you can hear me I assume yes
okay my question you you um you said you
want to get the most economical power
for your your town uh would that be then
that be the bottom line I believe
represent Harrington is a
co-sponsor I thought as a co-sponsor I
could speak I thought it was just the
prime sponsor am I couldn't speak so I'd
like to know what the what the
clarification is here all right I'm not
sure the rule you want to know the truth
I'm asking Mr chairman yeah the vice
chair is currently speaking with the
clerk to get clarification on this rule
right well I'll just hold my question
then it'll be back to you in a few
seconds so representative Harrington
hang on to your question and I'll
recognize uh representative ssuch in the
metime thank you very much Mr chairman
and thank you uh uh uh Rebecca for
coming to testify um let me ask you uh
this is kind of a a community question
uh do you believe that this opportunity
for Community power is a motivating
factor in your community uh for being
able to take some local control about
your energy use absolutely we're so much
looking forward to uh becoming more uh
um educated and involved in this
uh special opportunity for creating um
energy Innovation and also economic uh
Advantage for our community our
community is a community that has a 14%
poverty rate and uh absolutely the uh
expense of energy if at all possible to
be reduced in our community would be
very important thank you for asking
thank
you thank you we still are waiting for
clarification from uh the clerk's office
about co-sponsor asking questions so
we'll move on to our next speaker and we
will recognize
Elizabeth Dragon you have the floor for
two minutes thank you Mr chair my name
is Elizabeth dragon and I am the city
manager for the city of Kean and I am
today um asking you to either itl this
bill as written or retain it um and and
I also um I submitted a letter in
opposition to the bill and I was asked
today to also mention a letter submitted
on February 10th that was signed by 11
Mayors for the communities of keen
conquer nashwa DOA Lebanon Claremont
Rochester Portsmouth Berlin Manchester
and recently Franklin has added um to
that letter as well in opposition to
House Bill 315
the city of Kean has a long history of
prioritizing initiatives that protect
our environment and our quality of life
in 2017 the Keen city council adopted an
energy resolution which among other
things sets us on a path for sourcing
100% of of our electricity for the
entire Community from renewable sources
by
2030 just last month the council adopted
an energy plan charting the path forward
Community power or AG ation is
identified as the single biggest tool
available to move our community towards
that goal in Keen we have both an active
energy Community Committee and Community
power committee we have a draft
Community power plan and have been
engaging the public in Outreach efforts
around this plan we are well on our way
to adopting a community power
aggregation plan for businesses and
residents all located within the city
boundaries and if you have a chance go
to our our website at ke ke Community
power.com and review that plan we have
concerns related to accessing uh the
customer data information that you've
heard many times already in testimony as
well as the ability to use our staff to
bring forward the plan for our community
to consider and I'm happy to answer any
questions that you may
have thank you very much we appreciate
your testimony I have a question for you
you think that the city of keen and the
you can't ask a
question oh are you a pro sponsor oh
that's right I'm a sponsor you're the
prime
sponsor all right you're right I can't
ask a question nobody else has a a hand
up to ask a question so we'll move to
the next Mr chair
yes oh I'm sorry there is someone who
has their hand up representative cam
brills is recognized for a question yes
uh I keep hearing the terms Community
aggregation and Community power my
understanding of it some people have
said that it means exactly the same
thing but others have said that
Community aggregation is a lot simpler
thing whereby
communities pull their resources
together so that they can buy make
contracts and get energy whereas
Community power it's a lot more
complicated where actually generating
electricity and no they therefore have
uh other obligations since you're
generating could you
maybe give a definition of the two or
are they in fact one of the same thank
you so it's my understanding that
Community power is using the community
aggregation uh law and in our case our
community draft plan um talks about
basically going out to bid for that
electric um service for our community
and so it's not creating our own power
and then selling it it's aggregating all
of our businesses and our residences
into one pool so that they can get a
better um a better cost for their
electricity and in addition to that we
have options which will move the
community gradually to more renewable
energy over a period of time and we've
surveyed our community to determine what
level of renewable energy they're
willing to pay for and at what cost and
so it is aggregation of power um and
then going out to bid for that
power thank
you so you no further questions for
IT Miss Dragon we'll move on and I will
recognize Phillip Stevenson Mr Stevenson
you have two
minutes uh thank you chair and thank you
uh committee members for listening to me
I'm a private citizen and energy
consultant I live in Hollis New
Hampshire um I oppose HB 315 and I'm
asking you to um vote at itl um I moved
to New Hampshire a year and a half ago
and was impressed to learn about the
community power law that had just been
passed RSA 53e um smart bipartisan
legislation that was putting energy
Innovation at the Forefront in the state
um and HB 315 would destroy that um as
written including with the amendment uh
which only only sort of um in a small
way undo the damage to to what was a
very
Innovative um piece of legislation the
rest of the country right now is mostly
divided into states where on the one and
Monopoly utilities completely manage the
power system and on the other state
legislators are making all the decisions
in 2019 New Hampshire carbed its own
Innovative path of bringing the power
back to the local level uh bad pun there
um and I'd ask that you not undo that
progress um I'd also just like to note
that I am a an observer a recent because
I have only recently joined but would
like to become a part of Hollis uh's
energy committee uh and when I um they
have also submitted comments so while
Hollis doesn't show up as a committee
that has signed on to community power uh
they have written comments to all of you
that include uh the concerns about this
HP 315 being anti- Innovative
anti-competitive and diminishing access
to competitive rates um and I would I
would emphasize that that is the issue I
I think that we should move this
conversation from HB 315 back to RSA 53e
and ask ourselves what are we trying to
achieve uh RSA 53e had very clear
objectives which is bringing the power
back to the taking the natural monopoly
components and separating them from the
non- Monopoly components of our
electricity system which is a great
thing and allows us to have local
communities private organizations being
Innovative on the parts that are
not manage the actual management of the
electrical system so let's ask ourselves
what are we trying to actually achieve
and as of the Senate bill and dealing
with issues like P let's focus on those
and get them fixed together as was
happening in the ru making this bill was
brought by one party who's unsatisfied
with the compromise level made so far
let's get back to the table on the
original Law and not try to overhaul it
this way um thank you all and appreciate
any questions you have for me thank you
appreciate your testimony although you
were a little longwinded
uh no more so than you sir I don't see
any hands raised for questions so we
will uh move
on next person on the list is Howard
KET or C Mr KET or k you have the floor
for two
minutes thank you Mr
chairman
um first of and uh also want to thank
committee members as a resident of Ryan
the energy committee I oppose the house
bill
315 Community power and Community
aggregation are the same Community power
provides an opportunity to provide local
control renewable energy and Innovation
and direction to all residents of Ry as
a resident and energy Committee of Ry we
have been forming plans to take
advantage of RSA
53e which is now threatened by HP
315 there's been much discussion today
by those much more knowledgeable than
myself but I do want to include my
concerns put them on the table I do
support comments from Mr Belo and Mr Len
uh find a lot of similarities in what
they've
said the ability to lower costs by
purchasing power on a wholesale basis is
key additionally power could come from
local sources Renewables green energy
suppliers note that local power
reduces uh capacity demands and
transmission costs large customers have
the access to competitive markets small
customers simply do not have this access
large customers have interval
metering to better understand usage and
lower costs once again smaller customers
do not have this option and other load
management oportunities the most
expensive power is at Peak energy usage
periods HP 315 would not specifically
encourage load management conservation
and Energy Efficiency
RSA 53e streamlines the enrollment
process for utility default service this
is a large piece of the community power
startup cost I look forward to guidance
from others to lead us and allow Ry to
reach our
goal please do not support this bill and
allow other local communities to provide
Power at lower costs with Greener
potential thank
you thank you uh we appreciate your
testimony thank you for being here thank
you for the edification of the committee
I just received word from the house
clerk that co-sponsors of a bill can ask
questions as long as they aren't
testifying or asking impertinent
questions that was his exact
phraseology so I will permit questions
from Representatives C pittz
representative Harrington representative
Thomas and of course myself so with that
clarification I see that there are no
hands raised for questions of Mr KET so
we will now proceed to our next qu
presenter who is Annie Henry Miss Henry
you are allowed to speak for two minutes
Miss Henry don't forget to unmute
hello thank you this is actually not
Annie Henry my name is Dory drachman and
I think I've I'm joining through a
different Zoom account which labels me
as Annie Henry so I am I'm sorry for
that for that confusion but my name is
Dory drachman and I am from Peterboro
New Hampshire I am a volunteer
with the community power Coalition of
New Hampshire and also with the manad
sustainability Hub a regional nonprofit
I am opposed to HB 315 and hope that the
committee will deem it
itl my main purpose for speaking now is
to in a an aggregate sense dispel the
idea that was brought up on uh the first
part of the hearing that very few
communities have shown interest in
community power as it exists in RSA
53e as you have heard from Individual
other communities this is definitely a
false um 471 people have signed into
this Committee in opposition to the bill
whereas only 11 have signed in as uh
supporting it um over 700 New Hampshire
citizens represent resenting over a 100
New Hampshire towns have signed on to a
citizen's petition opposing this bill
but even more important than those easy
steps of just signing your name there
have
been many many communities that have put
in significant time to learn about and
move forward with their Community power
programs um and as you know it's hard
it's complicated and so it's it it
implies a very significant interest in
it um in June
cpcn uh had held a summit and at that
Summit were 86 elected officials staff
and energy committee members that
represented 23 towns five cities and one
County it represented all of the all of
the New Hampshire counties wor
represented
and significantly it represented 25% of
the Statewide utility load 30
seconds with with the madn
sustainability Hub we have been um we
have offering Regional meetings and have
had 15 communities participate in them
uh two of which you've heard today
Harrisville and Keen have already been
um moving forward with their plans and
the others are very interested in the
bill that has already or in the law that
has already been passed and it has it is
through those Innovations in the current
law that get most of our communities
very excited okay thank you much glad to
hear there are excited communities out
there are there any questions for M
uh dman dman sorry I forgot your name
couldn't see it on the screen okay you
don't have it written in front of you
representative Cali pittz is recognized
for a question miss dman when yes you
talk about Community power and that the
community is interested that's either
the town or the county
municipality would the town County or
municipality have to take every customer
into their system including those
customers
who sometimes default on their
payments or can't afford the payments
that is gonna it's just a
question yes so and a fair question um
so yes it is an OP out program so that
anybody who is currently on the default
utility uh account would then be in the
community power program including those
that don't have um the the best record
of of ontime payments but that's where
this P I believe those are the initials
uh uh Amendment come in and it gives the
community power um program the same
right that the utility does to recoup
the the Mis
the the lapsed uh
payments can I follow up follow up I I I
just want you to follow up with that and
think that someone who lives in a
town pays their taxes but runs into
trouble with with um paying the electric
bill whatever uh is going to be treated
differently than
somebody who pays their taxes and does
pay their electric bill so that the same
benefits that the town offers through
some of the tax money which would be
startup and ever wouldn't be available
to that person so I I wonder how does
that work as are those the kinds of
things that the Pu is trying to work
out so so I I need to be honest that I'm
not an expert on the Pu and so I would
leave that that to other people who know
more about that I was not trying to
communicate that that that people who
couldn't pay their bills would be
treated differently in fact I was trying
to say that they would be treated the
same and that we would be accepting all
all rate payers and would have the same
uh recourses that a utility that the
utility has now um that was what I was
trying to communicate and I'm sorry if
that wasn't clear thank
you sure
thank you representative Thomas has
recognized for a question thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um since we just heard um that there was
no difference between Community power
and Community
ucation uh to avoid further confusion
would you be opposed if we just struck
out the word Community power throughout
the entire Bill and just stuck with
community agregation so we don't have
ask these these questions keep being
answered what the difference is since
there is
none so I can give you my opinion I
would like to keep the term Community
power for a couple of reasons one is
that it has now been a year and a half
since the the law has been in effect and
that's what people know about in New
Hampshire they know Community power my
understanding is that um Clifton Belo
who was the primary author of of that
bill chose the term Community power
because it is a more accessible term
than Community aggregation it has um
people can understand it more than what
you mean by aggregation I think that the
um I think that the confusion comes in
that there are just like in community
aggregation there are different models
of it and what this law does is this
is a very Innovative model of community
aggregation it allows towns and other
municipalities to to really be you know
the the authors of their energy future
by using Innovation and Market
competition and so I would say keeping
the name would be helpful because that
is what we have already been
using follow up
um okay thank you for that um I think
there's other people that may have a
slightly different view so would you uh
agree then that at the very least that
in the bill in any amendment that we
come forward that we at least to define
the two specifically in in there so that
we don't have this confusion in in the
future I would say that defining
Community power as the same as Community
Choice ever aggregation might be a
helpful piece to add but I would want
that to be very clear that they are the
same thank
you thank you representative Harrington
is recognized for a question thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question actually I got two specific
ones I'll have a follow-up coming first
one has to do with the discussion we was
just held about delinquent accounts
there I just want to make sure I get
your understanding of this correctly
presently the uh if someone doesn't pay
their electric bill over an extended
period of time eventually the uh that
fee is basically allocated to all rate
payers uh through the puc uh for the the
utility to be made whole and my question
is if somebody was in a situation where
they were delinquent on their bill and
then they became part of a community
aggregation would that delinquency come
with them and then be I guess eventually
spread out to the community aggregation
members or would it retain with the
utility and they would simply charge all
rate payers in the state a little bit to
pay for
it so that is a level of
detail that I am not um I'm not
knowledgeable about and I apologize for
that I um I would I would refer you to
uh Clifton Belo um or Bob Hayden um as
two folks who have spoken today that
would I believe be able to speak to
those that question much better than me
fair enough thank you uh followup Mr
chairman followup it's not really a
follow-up it's a different subject to
some extent what do you how do you
envision uh the use of meters I mean
somewhere along the line we' have to
have a revenue grade meter and if that
meter was going to also be used to build
transmission and distribution charges to
the utility as well as electric power
charges to the Consortium or the
community aggregation would you envision
two meters or one meter that was owned
by who and would it be required to meet
the present pu requirements for
calibrations and standards that have to
do with
meters well first of all I would say
that um metering and getting new meters
would not be something that would happen
right away um I believe as you know as
other folks have talked about this there
is kind of a basic Community power and
then there are some some more of these
Innovative aspects of it so the basic
Community power of aggregating
electricity on behalf of all of your
residents and businesses is something
that does not require a new meter um
down the line it could and at that point
I think that the market will have
changed enough that it I I can't say for
sure whether it would make sense to have
two meters or replacing the meter that
we've got now or having something that
you can add to the current meter so I
think that there would be a lot of um of
unknowns because it wouldn't be
something that would be happening right
now then follow up again Mr chairman yes
follow up okay this will be the last one
um it's having to do with the meters the
first phase very inquisitive using the
meters that are presently installed so
would you envision that the utility
would continue to read the meter and
send out I guess they'd send a bill for
transmission and distribution to the
individual and then send another bill to
the Consortium or the or the the the
town or whatever is running this
aggregation so that they could then in
turn build their
member um I don't know the answer to
that one either I could see that in
depending upon how this turns out if
we're going with 53 RSA 53e I could also
see that the community power company
could also be reading that meter um but
again these are these are um details
that
unfortunately as a as a community
organizer and Advocate I am not as up on
as some of the other aspects of
it okay thank you very much uh
representative Sage is recognized for a
question yes thank you Mr chairman and
and thank you uh Miss Henry for taking
my question um do you do you see um in
light of the fact that most bigger
businesses in this state are already
aggregating their needs and getting good
prices you see the community power act
as as as a vehicle allowing more
residents and municipalities to do the
same thing
absolutely that's a that's a very good
question and yes it has been a long time
coming um as you mentioned that
commercial uh entities have had this
opportunity for many many years and you
know anybody who has tried to um get
third third party supply on their own
knows that that is just not what has
been available to the average resident
and so this this is really the first
time because of being able to Leverage
The The Whole Town's load um when going
out to get energy it's the first time
that residents have been able to reap
that that benefit followup Mr chair
follow up uh and U you we you were
discussing a little bit with represent
Harrington about the issue of uh
individuals who might be def uh
defaulting on their payment
um uh if I understood correctly the
concept that you were
describing uh if a municipality actually
ends up getting a better rate for
everybody in their Town even the person
who is uh in default of that bill would
actually be defaulting on a lower lower
price Bill isn't that
correct yes that is correct that is
correct and one thing that I didn't
mention yeah oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I
interrupted so what I'm saying is
they're they're being treated actually
better than they would be under the
regular utility
system they very well could be the the
other piece that I think is important to
know is that with the um the current law
it is a requirement that the uh
Community power plan has a mechanism for
those folks who are on energy assistance
to be included into the plan um so and
that is something that we feel really
strongly about because it it really
makes Community power even more of an of
a a vehicle for Equitable an equitable
transition thank you very
much thank you seeing no more questions
uh I will call on our next presenter who
is Victoria paraly miss paraly you have
the floor for two
minutes don't forget to
unmute sorry sorry about that I I didn't
realize I actually got on the list um
I've just been listening to a lot of
what's been said and um I tremendously
admire the work uh of those who are
speaking against this bill I think the
the uh it's been made very clear why it
should not have come forward and that it
is a complete waste of everyone's time
um that's really pretty much what I need
to say um and I hope I hope that the
committee will itl this Bill thank you
okay thank you very much we appreciate
that next up is
um see has not
spoken Nick craco
two minutes Nick yeah thank you chairman
Bose and honorable committee members um
my name is Nick C from the conservation
law Foundation I appreciate the
opportunity to comment on HB
315 HB 315 is essentially a solution in
search of a problem that would only
provide benefits to New Hampshire's
utilities at significant cost to New
Hampshire's M municipalities and rate
payers SB
286 which greatly strengthen the
effectiveness of New Hampshire's
Community aggregation ation law was
signed into a law less than two years
ago by Governor senu the current
Community power law will work to allow
several municipalities to provide
Community power aggregation assume local
control over their energy resources and
services and rest control of the
provision of electricity to Monopoly
Utilities in contrast proposed HB 315 is
an anti-competitive and anti-market Bill
that serves no other purpose than to
reestablish utilities Monopoly control
over Municipal energy markets HP 315
would undo the Innovative aims of the
current Community power law and would
significantly limit Community Choice and
local control of energy resources and
services which the current law enables
HB 315 would also prevent municipalities
from prioritizing clean renewable energy
generation and other energy resources
such as Energy
Efficiency would impose reasonable
burdens on the ability of municipalities
to form Community power
aggregators and some because HP 315 is
unneeded only benefits New Hampshire's
Electric utilities and harms New
Hampshire's municipalities and Rays seof
urges the committee to reject the bill
and vote inexpedient to legislate thank
you for your time and I look forward to
asking to answering your
questions thank you we appreciate your
testimony anyone have a question for Mr
krov
if not I will
recognize Henry
hen for two minutes Mr henin two minutes
thank you Mr chair my name is Henry
hearnden I am an energy professional and
I'm working with numerous communities
across the state to educate them about
the potential of community power and
I'll be very brief uh in in my the
issues I want to address I'm opposed to
House Bill 315 I think it should be
voted itl or retained at the very least
I want to call the committee members
attention to three aspects of the bill
that I think are re reasonable one we've
heard about the purchase of receivables
and I believe that is new section six um
under billing Arrangements uh which
which I think is reasonable and agreed
to by all parties the second is uh
technical detail about new customer
enrollments which I believe is in the
amendment Roman uh six on page three
this refers to uh the manner in which if
a new customer hooks up to the grid they
would first enroll in the utility power
and then periodically the community
power program could could ping the
utility to enroll them in their um
Community power program just a technical
fix that I think all the parties agree
to so that's the second one is new
customer hookups and then um the third
thing I'm I'm happy to talk about the
metering question if folks have
questions on that but I want to be clear
there's some sort of fear mongering and
and and hysteria sometimes around the
meter issue but there's a clear narrow
regulated process in the existing RSA
53e that allows for a couple of of ways
for a community to implement metters if
they would so choose that wouldn't cause
cost to shift onto any other customers
um and and I can direct you to that
portion of the statute and um would be
happy to speak more about that um the
final thing that I'll that I'll mention
here this sort of community power
Community aggregation it's all semantics
and they're all just referring to this
policy in general so I think you know
sometimes there's there's misinformation
that comes out through these processes I
think some some of the parties um you
know they're masters of of confusion and
misinformation so that they' theyve sort
of used that to spread confusion in this
particular instance but uh I agree with
what Dory dman said about really
Community power is relatable you'd call
it Peterborough Community power
conquered Community power nashv
Community power whatever you might have
um and we should just put aside the
confusion that's been spread around that
issue because they all refer to the same
thing the final thing I'll mention is I
I'd like to participate in any uh
processes if there are discussions about
how we can move this piece of
legislation forward if there is work to
uh to to fix it up um and with that I
I'd be happy to take any questions from
any of the committee members thank you
for your
time thank you any questions as
representative Thomas has recognized for
a question thank you Mr chairman thank
you for Tak my question again getting
back to community power um uh so okay so
the community power and aggregation are
are the same thing so uh do you think it
would be okay then if the communities
that you know conf with Community power
would it be okay if they would if they
would since they would be having the
same Services as say any other utility
then it would be okay to have the Pu
regulate them just like the utilities
are since you're provided the same
Services I I would disagree with that
the purpose of the public utility commit
mission is to regulate the natural
monopoly of the distribution utility
that maintains the distribution grid the
low voltage electric distribution grid
and not to regulate competitive retail
customer services or wholesale power
markets which Community power could
engage in so um I would I would not say
that these programs should be regulated
by the Public Utility Commission I think
that would be um that would defeat the
purpose of
innovation follow up yes thank you uh
Ken uh oh okay so uh I'm just curious as
I don't know how how this exactly would
work how do we resolve differences
control uh or avoid situations like they
had back in the turn of the other
century when they had wires everywhere
how do we how do we control and regulate
that make sure that one one entity
doesn't become so powerful that they
themselves Monopoly I don't understand
how that might work I I I think I
misunderstood the question and I think I
understand it better now um so for
particular um issues such as the
metering issue um no Community the way
the law is written is no Community can
Implement meters without going through a
Public Utility Commission regulated
process that would approve that is in
the public good and I would direct your
attention to RSA
53e
specifically uh section four regulation
Roman IV or Roman 4 and what it says
there is for the purposes of obtaining
interval meta data meter data for load
settlement the provision of Energy
Services and near realtime customer
access to such data a municipal or
County aggregator may contri there's
three options one may contribute to the
cost of the utility provided meter two
jointly own a revenue grade meter with
the electric utility or three provide
its own meter and pay for the cost of
that and that would be in addition to
the utility meter and the only way you
can do any of those three options is if
you go through a regulated Public
Utility Commission process that the
Public Utility Commission approves
that's in the public good so there is a
very narrowly defined process for the
metering issue um I hope that helps to
to clarify this particular
question one more thank you okay thank
you uh thank you very much so so um so
what you just explain this covers not
only the initial um you know process to
set it up but it would cover for All
Time Eternity for all ongoing Services
they would come under the same uh
regulation is that what you're saying
for for every
member I I don't know that I understand
the question but I don't I don't agree
that we should impose strict regulation
on competitive markets for services I'm
a proponent of of free markets and and
Market competition and I believe that
the market is left When there's less
government sort of meddling and
intervention there and and I understand
there's a necessity for regulation over
the Monopoly utility company as it owns
the poles and wires and it makes sense
to just have one set of poles and wires
and we have to ensure that they are not
uh extracting excessive uh profits from
people who are captive to that Monopoly
utility but if there are any aspects of
the market that we can give to Market
competition and really let the the
customer choose I think the customer
will will know best
thank you you're very clear thank
you okay representative McGee has
recognized for a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr hearnen for
your testimony um I I'm looking at uh at
53e as really part of the growing pains
coming out of our grid modernization and
deregulation of the Monopoly utilities
and I wonder if you could speak to um
to to to representative Thomas's
question if you could speak to the need
for definition of how Community power
will actually interact with the
utilities because I think that's what
people keep grappling with so since you
work in that space can you just speak to
that portion of it yeah I think it's a
great question and I'll I'll just by by
way of answering I'll let the committee
members know that I conducted Master's
uh thesis research on Public Utility
Commission here in New Hampshire and I
looked at a number of policies including
Grid modernization at the Public Utility
Commission that's been ongoing for the
past six years and what has become clear
is that regulated attempts to modernize
our electric grid have failed and have
stalled in the regulatory process so we
can't rely on sort of top- down state
regulation to to give us all these
Innovations we know about we know that
we could have in terms of time based
price signals battery storage
integrating Community Resources uh to to
lower cost and to lower things like
capacity cost and transmission cost and
that's where Community power comes in as
a vehicle to partner with the utility
company to achieve those ends and I
think the utility partnership is a key
piece we hear about Liberty Utilities
they've been a leader they have an
Innovative home battery storage pilot
program and they're going to work with
the city of Lebanon on their Community
power program and it really is a
partnership we talked about data sharing
and we need the utility to share the
necessary data with the community power
aggregation so that they can um go get
pricing and purchase power for their
customers and the meter is sort of this
shared resource that's collecting that
information that's necessary for the
utilities business model and that's good
but it's also necessary for Community
power to be successful and really add
values to our community so so this is
all a way of saying that Community power
is a means to use the market to achieve
a modern Energy System as opposed to
relying on regulation or Monopoly
utility companies that are great for
reliability and they do a really great
job but they're they're not capable of
innovation follow up Mr chair follow up
so is that is what you're saying that
this is simply a new
configuration in term you talked about a
partnership between people who are
working for local sustainable energy
within the communities and the utilities
learning how to work learning how to
coexist is that what you're saying
that's exactly right and I really do
believe that there are a lot of
opportunities for Partnerships take NH
saves in the efficiency programs for
example the utilities currently
administer efficiency programs on behalf
of our state and there's an opportunity
for Community power to then work with
those utility program administrators to
make sure the efficiency dollars are
getting into their communities in the
best ways to low lower costs for
individual residents but also for the
system as a whole so I think I think the
partnership piece is really key here and
and it's sort of it's an alter
alternative but it's it's the New
Hampshire way we've looked around at
other states and they have topped down
mandated procurements top down
regulation and I think there's this
really exciting opportunity for New
Hampshire to maybe Leap Frog over some
of those and take the free market
approach take the local control approach
and and that's why I'm working so hard
on community power thank
you thank you uh representative
Harrington is recognized for a
question muted here thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question it sounds like you're very
knowledgeable on the subject so I'll ask
you the question I asked the previous
speaker who wasn't able to answer it can
you tell us your how you envision
metering working here would it be two
meters one meter who would own them uh
who would read them how would billing be
done for transmission and distribution
as well as for this bulk power
consumption thank you for your question
representative uh I would Envision that
in initial programs the utility owns the
meter and they collect the meter data
and in order for the community power
program to go and get pricing and to go
and know how much electricity it needs
to buy they would receive the data from
the utility via their electronic data
interchange or their service provider or
the community power Coalition would
receive all of the meter data from the
utility this is how competitive
suppliers currently work if a supplier
wants to sell electricity to any large
customer they get the data from the
utility company so there's a process by
which the utility shares meter data with
Community power aggregators down the
line there are opportunities for meters
that instead of collecting information
once monthly meter that collects
information during the day to know to to
be able to provide some of those those
more Innovative Services where you're
responding to prices in real time we
heard Clifton Belo talk about how they
reduce their capacity cost enormously by
just responding to the real-time price
there's a lot of untapped potential
there so down the line it's a question
of um will there's one of those three
paths will the utility invest in a smart
meter and then share smart meter data
with the community or will the community
invest to their own meter and they'll
put that alongside the utilities meter
and use that meter I I hope that gets at
your question it's a good question and I
and I think it's uh will will Merit much
more
discussion followup Mr chairman follow
up yeah yeah thank you um I you sort of
anticipated my next question which was
going down the Road of um time of use or
realtime monitoring uh it would seem and
that's why I'm you're asking for an
opinion on this that if we're really
going to make use of savings say say
typically in say like a residential town
where their electric use between the
hours of 8 and five is somewhat reduced
because everybody's well assuming we get
back to normal they're off to work or
school or something and a lot of those
houses wouldn't be using that much
electricity during the peak times
especially in the summer um would that
with Advanced metering then give them
the option of having a a much better
profile and subsequently a much better
price from A supplier yes you are
exactly right representative the purpose
of the the advanced metering
infrastructure is to harness the load so
you can you can you your pricing comes
based upon are you using electricity
when it's expensive or are you using
electricity when it's cheap and once you
have a smart meter you can begin to
understand
CommunityWide okay these certain
customers they're really driving up our
cost because they use electricity at the
peak times let's provide a specific
service to those customers where we're
going to install batteries or Energy
Efficiency measures or just ask them to
curtail their their energy usage
processes and and give them a a discount
for that because that will lower the
costs for all of us and you can't really
do that on a one by one customer by
customer but once you have a whole city
or a town with a community power program
you can really start to look at okay how
can we lower people time usage across
the entire community and drive down our
capacity costs and drive down our
transmission costs and maybe there's a
way where we could uh construct a new uh
solar plus storage facility in the
community and use that to do the same
thing to to discharge power into the
Grid at the time of high cost and lower
cost for our community as a whole so I
think I think you're exactly right that
this is some of the these are some of
the complex aspects of community power
that um folks who really really like the
weeds of the energy industry get really
excited
about okay thank you representative
ssuch is recognized for a question thank
you Mr chairman and thank you uh Mr
Hearn for taking my question um so if I
understood you correctly um any any type
of um structure in a community power
entity W would be first would have to
first go through some kind of pu process
to to
ascertain that this is a a verifiable
and and sanctioned process is that
correct uh no representative the the
community power program if they wanted
to do metering then they would have to
go through a regulated Public Utility
Commission process it is my
understanding that under the current law
RSA
53e there is you're not subjected to
Public Utilities Commission regulation
this is perhaps a third point that is
merits discussion in this and I
understand Clifton Bel has done some
thinking and some drafting around this
but in the original draft of House Bill
315 it said every uh city or town would
have to go to Public Utility Commission
regulation to get approved and a lot of
us got scared and we said oh no that
could slow things down for years and
that would be difficult and and there's
a potential compromise there where a
city or town could submit its Community
power aggregation plan to the Public
Utility Commission and the commission
would have an opportunity to review it
and reject it within a limited time
window say 30 days um and provide
comment on why that plan failed to meet
the statute so there's one potential
compromise where there could be a Way
Forward where you don't have arduous
long drawn out year-long adjudication
but maybe just there's a check where the
Pu looks at a plan and if they say
nothing after 30 days it's approved but
they can flag any red flags if they need
to uh followup Mr
chairman follow up uh and Mr Hen um
looking at the original HB
315 would you characterize that bill as
kind of a at least for some utilities as
a monopoly protection Bill and an
overregulation of community
power yes uh representative I think that
that is accurate I think that I tried it
at the in my testimony to highlight
three or three of the small areas that I
believe are reasonable and that there
are reasonable fixes to be made but the
vast majority of the bill there are many
many changes in the bill repeal and
replace strike words all over the place
replace language here and there and much
of that I don't see the public policy
purpose for and the effect of it would
be to curtail Market competition and
restrict Market competition which is why
I'm vinant opposed to the Bill thank you
thank you see no more questions for Mr
Heen we'll now turn to Cynthia Walter
Miss Walter you have the floor for two
minutes hello can you hear me you can't
we can okay great um yes thank you I'm a
DOA resident and I wish to State my
strong opposition to House Bill 315 in
addition to the testimony I emailed to
those of you um on in the committee on
February 21 I'm one to 400,000 citizens
whose Mayors oppose this bill and I
applaud my Mayor Bob carrier and his
colleagues this bill creates too many
expensive unnecessary restrictions that
disadvantage Community power aggregation
products projects the 2019 law should go
forward any adjustments can be made in
adjudicated regulations possibly even
including the P that was discussed
earlier most of House Bill 315 with
amendments um do not protect me instead
and they protect the old business model
of big energy corporations too much of
my money now goes to Big corporations
and out of our state also um these
corporations have to focus more on
profits Than Rap pairs instead I want
more of my energy bill to go to
Innovative local projects managed by
people I know and I don't buy the scare
stories from every Source such as meters
that mysteriously might not connect
instead I know we are smart enough here
to make sure local projects that use
Community power will use compatible
equipment and keep our energy
distribution consistent local energy
wins an efficiency too because big
Corporation energy means long
transmission lines where up to 90% of
the energy is wasted this is a fact of
physics diverse energy also makes us
more resilient during emergencies more
local projects also mean more good local
jobs listen to the facts please and
Common Sense and drop HB 315 thank
you thank you we appreciate that any
questions for Miss
Walter seeing none I will turn to our
next speaker who is mateline mano of
cleen energy New Hampshire Miss Mano you
have the floor for two minutes thank you
Mr chairman um clean energy New
Hampshire opposes House Bill 315 and
asks you to itl this bill we work
closely with energy committees and
municipalities throughout the state and
we've seen a lot of enthusiasm for the
potential of what community power can
offer we've also actively participated
in the pre- rulemaking stakeholder
process on this issue at the commission
some seem to want to draw a distinction
between Municipal aggregation and
Community power and I want to Echo those
that have said before that they are the
same thing they're simply different
versions of the same thing um eversource
wants to refer to Municipal aggregation
as the very basic 1.0 version while they
seem threatened by the more advanced 2.0
or 3.0 version where our communities
have more options to evolve their
programs House Bill 315 would lock New
Hampshire into the 1.0 or Massachusetts
model of Municipal aggregation that's
not what our towns and cities want they
want to have options opposing HB 315 is
about giving customers more choice
giving residential customers choice for
the first time here in New Hampshire
more options is good for customers and
more competition is good for
markets you asked us to be very specific
about what HB 315 would take away that
we need and I'll focus on two things we
need the ability to contract with local
generators therefore ccas should not be
forced to only procure power supply from
a broker and they must be allowed to be
Market participants and manage a
portfolio of resources it sounds like
your proposed amendments make that
slightly better but does not fully
address this
problem ccas should be allowed to offer
Energy Efficiency demand response
battery and Innovative rate structures
to be able to fully implement the
options and innovations that were
envisioned for our community power law
15 of restructuring is that utility
Monopoly be restricted only to
electricity delivery or distribution
there's no reason for them to hold on to
Monopoly beyond that and that is exactly
what house bill 315 is attempting to do
thank
you thank you any question for M
Mano see yes representative McGee is
recognized for a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Miss Mano for
your testimony um are you aware of a
citizen petition that was put around I
know when we had
heard when I know you work with a lot of
citizens and when we had heard the bill
uh in its initial session I had heard
that there was a petition that was being
submitted I don't know if it was
submitted to the
committee um that was not organized by
our organization but I am aware that one
was circulating um last I'd heard I
think there was over 700 signatures on
it but um that was not ours so Mr chair
I'm not sure if we've received that or
if maybe Jen knows about it I I know
there were people trying to MIT
something and I'm just wondering if that
came in as part of
testimony I believe it did I got it in
my inbox and it was addressed to the
house science technology and energy
committee okay thank
you thank you representative parshall is
recognized for a
question yes uh thank you chair and
thank you for your testimony uh Miss
Manel uh I think that the uh what we're
talking about the ition wasn't that part
of Andrea hodson's uh um testimony that
she submitted there was over 711
signatures on that petition I
believe and I see she still on maybe you
could ask her if you really need to know
this that's that's not so much of a
question forgive
me okay are there any other questions
seeing none chair now recognizes Peter
Hansel uh to speak Mr Hansel you have
two
minutes thank you for allowing me to
speak I I've spoken on some of your
earlier hearings and you you probably
familiar with some of this but I'm the
committee I'm the chairman of the city
of Kean energy and climate committee and
I'm also on the uh Community power
committee uh part of the plan you've
already heard from uh Elizabeth Dragon
our city manager and Bob Hayden who has
been hired by our city to uh help us uh
put together a community power plan and
uh what I'm most concerned about is the
the amount of time that this is taking
that would delay our process we have uh
we have a plan in front of us that we've
been working on for uh a while while our
our community uh sustain energy
sustainability plan has been a two-year
process and has been approved by our
city council uh unanimously just last
month but also along with that is our
community power plan which is a key
component of the sustainable energy plan
and we're we've been uh under the
impression that the Pu was going along
at a fairly good Pace to approve the
regulations that would allow us to put
this plan in action uh up until the
point when HB 315 was introduced which
seemed to uh uh Sidetrack that that
progress and uh I I don't want to add
much more to my testimony other than
what what Bob uh Hayden has said and our
city manager that we're all ready to
begin uh implementing a plan as soon as
the puc is finished and if HB 315 goes
through we would have a hard time seeing
that uh going forward so I urge you
please to uh vote no on HB 315 or or itl
it thank
you thank you representative partial rep
representative Pim Andel rather is that
recognized for a
question um thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you Mr Hamill uh for answering my
question
is it you you talked about uh everything
kind of the breaks going on everything
ever since HP 315 was uh
introduced uh is there going to be a
difference in how things progress if it
is ited as opposed to uh
[Music]
retained I do not know the answer to
that I've heard testimony just through
these hearings that there is a Senate
bill that covers a lot of the uh
concerns that the Pu has I don't know
anything about that bill um so I don't
know that for how that applies but I
think uh Bob Hayden's testimony
indicated that if you uh itl this bill
or retain it and concentrate on the
other bill it would probably resolve
some of the remaining issues that the Pu
has uh before it
thank you no followup no
followup okay good thank you I seeing no
further
questions and seeing no further hands
raised amongst the those in attendance I
think we can safely conclude that we can
adjourn this public hearing so that is
what we shall do at 3:24
I thank you all for your for
participation for the part two of this
uh hearing on HB 315 we had 120 people
who signed in in opposition to the bill
three who signed in in support of it so
we will now take a six minute break
until 3:30 at which time we will
reconvene and conduct some executive
sessions thank you I'll see you in uh
six minutes that's
that's
seven
all right let's go take look at those
bills not
okay
[Applause]
D here
okay for
3 148
13 for
7 11 a.m.
okay
H oh there this
[Applause]
that's for
okay welcome back
everybody I would like to now convene an
executive session on House Bill
371 that's
371 I recognize representative Thomas
for a
motion thank you Mr
chair I uh motion house
itl chair
recognizes representative
PL I second it's been moved and seconded
that we itl House Bill
371 is there any discussion
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman um isn't this the bill that was
asked for by um the consumer Advocate
that codified that the adjudicative
proceeding was the way that rate setting
would be done wasn't it like a I thought
it was a simple one I'm wondering why
we're iing it I didn't think we were
going to can you just tell
me yes it that this is the bill you're
correct it was requested by the consumer
Advocate and unfortunately at the public
hearing for the bill only the consumer
Advocate testified there was no
testimony from the Public Utilities
Commission but the Public Utilities
Commission reached out to a couple of uh
us on the committee
afterwards and in uh written letters
they indicated that this bill would
hamper their ability to conduct their
business that they would have to require
an uh hire another person in order to do
the extra work that would be involved
and that it would U require more time
to handle all the the matters that they
they handle on a day-by-day
basis representative Harrington spent
more time talking to them that I did and
he can tell you more so I'm going to
recognize representative Harrington
right now thank you thank you Mr
chairman yeah I spoke to uh the chair of
the Pu a couple of times over the
weekend on this and the basic issue is
is just as the chairman had stated but
also with the new twist that was uh came
out after this bill was originally
proposed and that's the uh I guess will
be hb2 reorganization of the Public
Utilities Commission and really need to
see how that shakes out first before we
start imposing any new types of edicts
on them just think that that's not going
to be come to fruition till I don't know
I guess sometime in the summer or
whatever then we could certainly come
back and look at this again for
something similar to this or maybe not
you know maybe not quite so similar
depending on how that reorganization
comes out and we can address it at that
time that's what they've requested and
it seems to make sense to me not in the
middle of a reorganization don't try to
impose something on there that they
think they're going to have trouble
working with thank you for the
explanation I and I appreciate your your
your willingness not to unduly burden
the Public Utilities Commission but I
think what is interesting here is that
the language I'm looking at it that it
says proceedings of the commission every
proceeding conducted by the commission
to determine rates and charges of a
public
utility so it's not all of their
procedures it's the procedures that are
considered adjudicative now and so what
I heard from the consumer Advocate was
that he was the one that surfaced the
fact that that there was sort of a
sliding or a bending of the rules that
they were not
um not always adhering to using an
adjudicative procedure and they were
saying that they might sometimes
consider themselves a legislative body
for the purpose of making these
decisions and skirt the idea of all of
the due process that they're required to
do so this doesn't say everything they
do it doesn't say Ru making or all the
it doesn't list it's very specific it
just says to determine rates and charges
of Public Utilities so that's why I'm
confused because I don't this is what he
explained was that it was a
clarification of what is in law now but
it is more explicit so that there is no
ability
to skirt the process that was intended I
guess by the Public Utilities Commission
representative Harrington uh do you
remember the specific instances cited in
the uh commissioner's letter about the
kinds of things that would be impeded um
I have to I could pull it up if you just
be me for a second please I'll I'll try
to get to that someone else wants to
speak go ahead yes thank you I was uh
particularly concerned by some of the
types of activities that indicated would
be impeded uh by this legislation I was
also kind of somewhat
distressed that the consumer Advocate
and
the chair of the puc couldn't work this
out between them I mean they're both
lawyers they understand the implications
of of the legal issues here I was quite
disappointed that they couldn't come up
with some kind of a compromised position
on this that would allow the committee
the commission to do its business in a
straightforward way uh while still
giving the consumer Advocate the
assurance that he would need that the
committee
is following a judicative legal
procedure so
uh I think is is reason enough to itl
this bill because um we should ask those
two folks to go back to to the table and
see if they can come up with some some
compromise uh language for legislation
of this
sort were able to find that letter I'm
still looking I was uh because it didn't
come directly from Diane it came from l
so I have to check it out that way um I
think they'd be both open to that I know
uh the chair of the Pu said that she was
more than willing to sit down and and
work out something on this they just
didn't have the opportunity to do it at
this
time let me see where am I here while
you continue to look for that letter I'm
gonna recognize Rec representative
oxenham for a question or for a
discussion thank you very much for
taking my question I'm really puzzled
that there is a discussion going on
about letters that have gone to certain
members but not other members about
testimony that has been provided not in
the course of a public hearing I I don't
think that this is a proper legislative
procedure and I I would request that
that this be
clarified what's not SL you raise a good
point I uh uh will acknowledge that um
the Pu did not show up for the public
hearing and therefore did not testify
right then they did also reach out to
both myself and to representative
Harrington um privately or non-publicly
I guess you could say it um they never
told us that we couldn't share any of
the information that they shared with us
uh otherwise we wouldn't be talking
about that right now
but especially if it's influencing the
decision of how we're going going to
dispose of the bill that's I think the
point that that representative oxenham
is making yes well uh I agree with her
and that's why I'm hoping representative
Harrington can find the letter that U
came
from the puc commissioner because uh she
listed some very specific activities
that would be harmed in her judgment by
this legislation and to me they were
persuasive so I'm hoping he can find
that and maybe if you can't
representative Harrington maybe I can I
can look you EXC you think perhaps found
the
letter okay representative Harington
could you share that with us yes it's
pretty short and I can also you know
email it to people as well I'll just
send it to every all committee members
just says the Public Utilities
Commission takes no position on HB 371
however we offer the following your
consideration regarding potential
unintended consequences and legal effect
of the legislation there number of
matters that come before the commission
that can be resolved in an efficient
manner to not generally involve full
litigation as this bill would seem to
require these include annual adjustments
to line extension policies qualified
Capital adjustment charges water
infrastructure conservation adjustments
and minor tariff changes including those
for late fees meter testing rate case
expenses and temporary to permanent rate
recoups among others it appears that the
effect of this legislation would requir
these changes be subject to full
litigation which would Impact Staff
resources potentially require hiring
additional staff as well as create
additional regulatory leg with the
commission which the commission's
current flexible procedures are designed
to prevent we currently have a pending
matter regarding the substance of the
bill and are necessarily constrained in
our Communications of as a result
because that would be expar so that
that's it and not it sounds like it's
another bill that should be retained it
just sounds like these two parties need
to have a conversation about what the
language needs to be because I think I
think the intention of the consumer
Advocate was that it'd be very discreet
and if there's concerns by the chief
commissioner or the I don't know is that
what she's called the head commissioner
woman yeah that it might spill over into
other things and and and be um untenable
then I I would imagine that that would
be easy to resolve so rather than itl it
can't we just retain it and fix it
representative here it's disc courteous
committee members to speak without being
recognized because you deprive them oh
I'm sorry to speak so if you could just
raise your like everybody else I'll be
sure to call for recogniz you because I
always enjoy what you have to say but I
wish you would do it in turn so that
other people can
[Music]
have representative man you're
recognized Jo the discussion don't
forget to unmute thank you Mr chairman
yeah I was just going to support the I
the um um um
retain
idea I think it needs I think it needs I
think we need to understand it before
much better than we do before we um make
a decision and I think retain is the
only way to do that well itl is another
way but uh it looks like it's worth um
working on that's it representative
thank you Mr chairman my I I want to
just uh Echo some of the comments that I
think that if if um if members of of the
uh committee leadership receive these
kind of letters we probably should get
copies of those letters or um emails
because what representative Harrington
just read sounds like a
testimony and normally like you said the
Pu was not there testify so we couldn't
ask questions so I would just request
that if something like this happens in
the future that copies of those be made
available to the Democratic side as well
uh but I did have a you know I I'm I'm
also curious about the fact that and
maybe representative Harrington is the
best one to answer this since he served
on the Pu uh what exactly did the
consumer advocate mean when he thought
that the Pu in some instances is doing
what he called a quasi legislative
process and that's where he had some
objections representative
Harrington trying to he we okay I think
I'm unmuted now I'd have to go back and
look at the specifics on that I know it
was in a particular ruling that they
made uh last uh fall that uh brought the
thing up I I just don't have it off the
top of my head I I could I could get it
someone if you want to find out what it
is but it was specific to a particular
ruling that came out of the Pu and I'm
sure Dawn probably has the information
on his fingertips but it wasn't like a
general at least I saw it as not being
as a general Trend if they were doing
something that he did didn't think was
proper but it was a specific case
involved thank you very much by the way
representative Harrington can you send
that letter to the members of the
committee working on it as we speak okay
good thank you representative Bern is
recognized to speak thank you Mr
chairman
uh um so as I understand
hb2 is causing a reorganization of the
Pu and and how they're going to conduct
some activities we have a conflict here
between uh the Pu and
uh on how how things need to be done
they need to work this out this bill
then is
really not written the way it needs to
be written to resolve that conflict so
itl seems like a very reasonable method
to address the problem and and they can
come back with with some piece of
revised legislation go forward once the
whole understanding of how the p is
going to operate when hb2 is implemented
it's
done okay thank you next up is
representative
pintel thank you Mr chairman um this is
all really kind of strange to me I mean
we had the the original hearing on
February 8th and then this
weekend uh representative Harrington
gets a letter that we don't know about
until right
now uh which all of a CH sudden is
changing what appeared to be and ought
to pass to an it
L
uh they would have known about this
hearing in the first place and and now
we're we being asked to itl a bill that
essentially uh Mr
C um
requested and we're giving deference to
a letter that was arrive to some people
over the
weekend and and and iing this bill it
seems that if we're going to give
difference to the Pu then it should be
to uh retain the bill and give both
parties uh some breathing room to to
work out their
differences uh but it Ling it just does
not make any
sense thank you that's it thank you uh
representative
until I would just say that you may re
may recall that at that public hearing
we had on February 8th I expressed my
displeasure and and
my dismay at the fact that the Public
Utilities Commission did not appear to
testify on that remember that and uh
when they contacted us um after the fact
I think they did so because they
believed that the issue under
discussion was about a docket that was
still open at the Pu and they felt that
by law they could not discuss the matter
at hand because of that open
docket and uh the restrictions about ex
parte Communications about open dockets
so I I sort of understand why they
didn't communicate with the full
committee about that but at the same
time I also understand why they decided
to reach out uh and express their
concerns in a kind of an unofficial
capacity and for my
own situation or my own uh feelings
about it I didn't rushed to inform the
rest of the committee about it because I
was unsure about whether this was that
could be shared or not so I just want to
make that clear to everybody Mr chair um
representative PL J is recognized for
for a comment I just want to make it uh
heard and open that you did not share
with anyone else other than Mr Thomas
because not only the Democrats the other
side did not here this
iset was just you and I'm sorry
represent
Harrington Harrington do you mean
representative
Harrington yes representative Harrington
and I were discussing what to do about
this because we weren't entirely sure
what the legal situation was um but we
decided we had to do something at this
point so followup I'm sorry my point was
that was just between the chair and
representative par
is that
correct well it was between yes the
chair and representative farington but
now we've made it the entire committee's
business
so uh chair now recognizes
representative cran for a
comment you Mr chair um I guess I'm a
little confused about why the the letter
from the Pu would be explicitly
on one one case um when this seems to
apply to any kinds of cases um and I
apologize that I can't speak to the
specifics that are in the ladder because
I haven't seen it but um from what
representative Harington said it sounded
like they were they had some examples of
specific cases where they felt like
adjusting rates um should follow a less
um Less open less judicative uh
procedure do you agree with that do we
need to put some else in statute to make
that clear what Things Fall above and
below this line or um sorry I'm not
being especially articulate but um it
sounds like there maybe is a great area
is that something that we should address
in legislation to your mind or does
anyone else have opinions on that
obviously that we should address this
legislation request to submit
the fact that the BC didn't respond put
us in
position Mr chair we cannot hear
you no I forgot to turn on I forgot to
unmute we heard
you what I was trying to say is that uh
obviously Mr cre thought that this was
an important issue but the fact that the
Pu didn't respond put us kind of in a in
a difficult position
because especially after they responded
to us kind of off the Record uh here we
had this information what are we going
to do with it and uh ultimately we
decided we had to uh reveal it and
ultimately we also decided that it
probably
warranted uh sending these two parties
back to the drawing board get them to a
table talking to each other and one way
to do that is to it this bill
representative Cali pittz has recognized
for a
comment well I want to thank the chair
for making this public but I I I think
that the lawyers on the commission know
better than to try to communicate or
Lobby in the
background I would say I would not itl
this bill I would hold it as a hammer uh
and that may sound a little bit harsh
but how do you get somebody to go to the
table if you don't have something and
say look you guys get together and talk
uh and we'll meet again in the fall and
this bill will either go forth or you
will have settled the problem and I I I
think that's what we need to do I I
think if we just itl
it it's not a very good idea at this
point not if we want to see results
thank
you representative is recognized for
don't we get the same place by itl it
bringing it back next year I'm concerned
about the number of bills who've already
retained how we can handle so with the
itl it doesn't mean it's dead it means
it's dead for this session and it comes
back next year in some
form um my is correct
representative in fact that did figure
into our decision Mak
do
and happen you
is offic
is man this button uh I do think that's
an acceptable solution this Linda get
the parties to talk to each other and
then bring us back something next year
that they can both live with
representative Harrington did you have a
comment uh no I'm sorry I thought I was
on mute I was talking to my
wife is
still um representative Thomas is
recogniz nice for a comment thank you Mr
chairman
um with the Pu
letter not withstanding that I haven't
seen um I I go back to the original
testimony of Mr C and it it did sound to
me that let me say that for the last
four years at
least has not had a problem with pu been
no issues there been no
no no things he thought was was
inappropriate in heing but it seemed to
me that in in his testimony there was
one
case that Disturbed him and he was
making his case on that one case I don't
believe that we should
write a
law a oneoff situation so that to me was
enough for me to decide that it should
be ideal what they wanted to discuss on
their own Act is up to them but uh I
don't see this as as problem at all so
that's
why representative oxen I'm recognized
for a
comment thank you very much Mr chair I
was going to read um from my notes of of
the last meeting I I think it's not at
all an issue about one case but but
rather than read I it seems to me Mr
cis's presid
we could ask him whether in fact this
comes from one case or whether as he
testified this was from his experience
both as general counsel of the Pu and as
a professor of administrative law that
there had been a a sloppiness in
procedure
that that adjudicative proceedings which
were you know characterized as vanilla
and then the this other uh form of
proceeding which was chocolate but
somehow a a new version of reality was
being introduced as a quasi legislative
and of course I think for every member
present the hairs on the back of our
neck stands up when when an agency
starts talking about being quasi
legislative and I think that was part of
the reason that we were all um so so on
board but could could we ask Mr CH to
explain further I I I I think this is a
Salient Point here
uh that's a uh legitimate question
representative oxam but it is my
understanding that since we're an
executive session we cannot ask Mr G
question I think we follow up by we
certainly have in the past we're not in
a work session we're in an executive
session and so I believe that that would
be a well well excuse me Mr chairman we
do not have work sessions anymore so we
can't ask anybody to clarify anything
anymore if we stick by that Orthodox
rule well that is true and if we were
living in a normal world I guess we
would have work sessions but we're not
we're living in a pandemic world so we
have to play the hand we're dealt and we
just don't have time to have work
sessions unfortunately so asking Mr Cree
to answer that question seems like a
very simple and not very timec consuming
thing to do and he's available so I
don't see why we're not doing
it well I just don't
understand whether the rules would
permit that I think they
would do or
don't email that we haven't
seen now there were three people talking
and I couldn't understand any of them
hand raised over here representative
Cali pittz could you tell us whether you
think I believe we can because if the
committee agrees we can ask somebody to
clarify something and that's not to give
a GU a try but to clarify and I and
that's been done before now whether it
was legal or not I don't know but it's
been done last 20 years that I
know okay well why don't we uh recess
this executive session then while
representative Thomas consults with the
clerk to find out if we can ask
questions during a exe session and then
uh we will reopen this executive session
later Mr chair of of point of order who
has a point of order representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chairman uh I I
I'm unclear but if we open up for
questions from the consumer Advocate to
address part of this bill don't we have
to then go back to the Pu and say you
need to comment and let's get the full
story otherwise we'll get half a
Lo that's a legitimate concern
legitimate
concern
so uh so all right so we will recess
this executive session and then
uh Mr chairman just a question for you
wouldn't wouldn't couldn't you have the
authority that you just recess this
session to open up a work session and
just for that one purpose and then close
the work
session then you don't have to ask
permission that's a reasonable uh
suggestion so let's close the work the
executive session on HB 371 and open a
work session on HB
371 so with this work session was there
a question uh representative
oxen I forgot
yes I the we're asking U Mr C to clarify
the issue surrounding the notion of a
quasi legislative procedure and whether
this was in fact a oneoff issue or
not uh Mr Cree could you answer the
question was this a oneoff issue or
not uh my answer first of all good
afternoon everybody and thank you for
letting me uh say a few things to the
committee
uh I would not characterize it as a as a
oneoff situation the commission has for
whatever reason uh asserted a I guess a
permanent right to uh make certain rate
decisions without conducting an
adjudication I I've actually seen the uh
communication from the chairwoman to
Representatives Harrington and Vose and
I agree with them that it would be
possible at least for me to address
their concerns but my my assumption has
always been that if you itl a bill like
this then the issue is dead for the
banum so I I would prefer to see it
retained uh the commission issued an
order on Friday that resolved the
pending issue that's actually before
them in an open docket so the EXP parte
problem that led the commission not to
appear and I have some sympathy for
their sensitivities around that that
resolved itself on Friday and that would
make it I think more possible for me to
have that kind of discussion with uh
chairwoman Martin and and as also has
been pointed out uh if the provisions
about reorganizing the Pu into a
department of energy in the uh Budget
Trailer Bill actually are adopted that
really will um I think um supersede the
conversation that we've been having in
the HB 371 context but we don't know for
sure that that's going to happen hope
that was responsive and then some to the
question was actually
asked okay thank you Mr GRE we
appreciate that okay
so uh representative Chan do you have a
question or a
comment or neither no I am sorry that
was from before oh okay thank you okay
so we've resolved that question so uh
you want to end the work session and go
back into executive
session see no objections to that uh
proposal we'll end the work session on
HB
371 and resume the exec session on HP
371 where there's a motion on the floor
by representative Thomas second by
representative plet to itl HB 371 is
there any further discussion
representative
McGee thank you Mr chair I was going to
unmute but I was already unmuted I was
just waiting for permission um so I I
understand the itail motion is the
motion that's pending um but we the new
information was to clarify whether or
not there was a purpose to retaining the
bill and whether there was a benefit to
the bill because itl inexpedient to
legislate means it's not worth our time
so I I understand you want to go to the
vote but the vote will then kill the
bill so I'm just curious whether we
think this can be resolved to everyone's
satisfaction so that we can actually
address the issue that the bill was
present presented to our committee for
in the first place rather than just
ignore
it I just don't think it's an I just
don't think it's an appropriate
um option to be calling for an itl on
this
bill okay representative
man thank you Mr Speaker I yeah I
believe the retain is you know it might
be an opportunity for the consumer
advocate the Pu to have discussions uh
with a with a with a retain hanging over
their head they they now really would
know that they'd have to they need to
resolve that issue and I think that
would be um I think that would work well
frankly it's just that it just forces
them to to come to a table I would
think thank you I appreciate the uh
motion I don't know if representative
Packard would appreciate it
um so you're in favor then
representative man of itl no I'm in
favor of um U
retain strongly in favor of retain
representative Bernardi is recognized
for discussion thank you Mr chairman I
just want to clarify the uh consumer
Advocate said that if the itail list is
dead for the bani I don't believe that's
true dead for this half the then it
opens up again
OPP for
next so if the real question is are you
going to retain it and with all the
other bills that deal with it to fall or
are we going to push it to next
year well there are what 60 70 house
rules so I'm sure you haven't had a
chance to learn them all yet but there
is a house rule that says if a bill is
defeated in the first year of a of the
biennium same bill can't be brought back
the second
year it would have to be a different
bill
so you are incorrect about that but I
can understand why you thought maybe
that wasn't true but it is a learning
process right so U representative uh G
now you've already had a chance to well
I wanted to just respond to that what
was just being said but you asked me to
raise my hand if I wanted to
comment but uh representative pel hasn't
had a chance to speak so okay first uh
thank you Mr
chairman uh do I got okay I'm off mute
um I I I'm hoping that uh that the uh
itl motion gets uh withdrawn so that we
can make a motion to
retain um
this isn't uh this isn't a big deal uh
to retain this bill this isn't going to
bury Us in work uh in the next half of
the year it's very simple it's a very
simple bill
um but it allows them to work together
to try and find out their differences
and um decide if it really needs
changing if in fact as uh Mr CH said
this is all about a bill which is uh an
issue that has now been resolved then um
you know maybe there should be no
objection to the bill as written now and
if it is something that is still an
issue maybe since the issue has been
resolved then Mr cre will make a a move
to change it more to their liking either
way I think we should retain it we
shouldn't kill the bill for two
years so let's just uh change the motion
and retain it and move on okay thank you
for that I I would ask the committee to
give us or your opinion of what
retaining the bill would look like what
what would the committee actually
do none of us are lawyers uh what would
we actually do if we retain this bill
well can we
speak
I if we retain it we don't really even
have to do anything we can do something
but we don't have
to it will either come back to us in the
same form in the fall in which case we
can have another hearing and they show
up for the exact same bill or the two of
them will work together to change the
bill
or we could do a subcommittee to try and
work this out but we don't have to do
that we can just let it come back just
the way it is without doing
anything hey to explain the process when
you retain a bill the bill itself
doesn't
change right all you do
is delay making a decision on it to give
you time to think about whether you want
to change it so it would be up to us to
change the bill
if we decide that's what we want to do
the other option would be to six months
from now just decide to itail it then or
pass it then those would be the other
two
options so I'm trying to get a sense
what the committee would like to do if
they retain this particular
Bill representative
ssuch uh yes thank you Mr chairman I I I
just like to make a motion to
to retain this
bill we already have a motion pending on
the floor so that's that's out sorry all
right representative McGee thank you I I
just wanted to clarify some things that
I'm
hearing if we itl the bill then the idea
is off the table and whether or not it
had Merit we'll never know um I believe
that what uh consumer Advocate Cree had
said was that that there was a a
proceeding going on at the
Pu that prohibited him from having this
conversation with the commissioner at
the time that that was resolved I guess
last week so now they can discuss it so
if there is something that the
commission has a problem with in the
bill I think it could probably be
resolved fairly easily but the idea of
an inexpedient to legislate designation
on a bill means that it isn't worth
anybody's time and there's nothing there
and that's why you try to kill it for
two years so I don't think this meets
that qualification I think that the EXP
parte communication with our committee
um was interesting um you know I but I
don't think we should respond to an
expart letter and let that govern the
disposition of the bill as if the
original presentation that was made to
us that there was a problem um
had no merit so I I feel like we're
making that decision by saying it's it's
not worth anybody else's time and so I
really disagree with the idea of just
getting it off our plate it it doesn't
seem like if these two parties who are
now able to talk to each other about the
issue can give us the answer that we
couldn't retain it and dispose of it
properly without a lot of work to to
somebody else's point that they already
made representative MC Williams is
recognized for
com um two things first I want to set
the record straight I'm a lawyer uh
second um I think it's important that we
do work with um both sides so if we
retain the bill we could ask for comment
or Amendment suggestions from both sides
so that's my two
cents my apologies for not remembering
that you were a
liyar uh representative Thomas has
recognized for comments thank you Mr uh
first i i i u I disagree with
representative assessment uh itl does
not necessarily mean that a bill is not
worth one's time it can mean many
reasons one uh and I've seen it happen
often where it's not a bad idea like the
bill but it needs so much work that uh
really needs to go back to the Joint
board and come up with some different
approaches and that's why it would be
itl another reason would be for obvious
reasons um the majority would feel it's
just a outright bad idea and they don't
think it should be pass law so there's
several reasons why one will itail this
bill other is might be legislature might
feel like you know they should not be
getting involved in this type of a law
should be worked out by some of method
which in the leads stronger to what I
believe that this bill is like and also
if we do ideal this bill and I I do not
intend to withdraw my my motion or ideel
uh if this is IDE then a bill can come
back next year if it is written in a a
different approach with a different
enough idea trying to get at the same
thing but it has different language and
maybe even has a potential solution in
this one if it's different enough and
the speaker allows it then it the bill
would be introduced and so it doesn't
mean that it's dead for next2 years but
I think this is the
case and if the two parties can work out
the differences and if they want to
codify it they can come back with
another bill which certainly would be
different than one that's now
that's a good point uh representative
Thomas representative partial you
recognized for a comment yes thank you
chairman um let me understand one thing
you said earlier may I ask a question
you said we could uh retain it and the
fall come back and either itl it then we
can also accept amendments to it as well
in the fall can we
not yes and I indicated that that was
another possibility okay forgive me I
guess I missed that segment of it um
I you said you wanted our um us to weigh
in I would weigh in to retain it that's
so we don't have to come back next year
and deal with it again it doesn't sound
like it's a very time consumptive uh
bill from our perspective as long as we
can get them to the table however I will
list in deference to whatever the uh
sponsor of the bill recommends I would
like to hear what he has to say about it
thank you
thank
you doesn't sound like it be a time but
we've been discussing it now for 45
minutes I
think ra my hand here sorry oh
representative recognize for comment yes
thank you um just in response to what
representative Thomas had said that if
we choose to itl this bill and then it
needs to come back next year it would
have to be in substantially different
form I guess I'm not convinced that as
written is not the best way of
addressing the issue that we think is
here um or maybe here uh so for that
reason I would be in favor of retaining
it rather than iing it to leave this
solution potentially on the table if we
do determine that it's
needed representative Harrington's
recognized for a
comment um I think we're kind of killing
this over over doing this uh I would uh
I could go either retaining it or it
Ling it because it's probably going to
be some change to it necessary due to
the reorg in the Pu there's certainly a
a good enough chance of that but uh I
also think we've probably spent enough
time on it now we should do something
one way or the
other okay seeing no further uh hands
raised and no further discussion on this
issue I'm going to ask the clerk to call
the role on the motion of itl on HB
371 Vice chair Thomas
yes uh representative Harrington yes
representative n yes representative mner
yes representative Platos yes
representative bery yes representative
Bernardi yes representative cell yes
representative Lo yes representative
white yes yes representative sage no
representative Kelly Pitts no
representative
man representative man no representative
Oxon no Representative Vincent no
representative McGee no representative
MC Williams no Representative chisan no
Representative
pel no Representative pasel no uh
chairman
votes chair votes yes okay and that's 11
to
10 okay by a vote of 11 to1 the bill is
judged to be
ITF so with that we will close the
executive session on HB 371 and open an
executive session on HB
294 and the chair recognizes
representative Bernardi for a motion
thank you Mr chairman
iose itl for HP
294 the chair recognizes representative
white thank you chairman I'd like to
Second it has been moved and seconded
that we itl HB
294 the floor is open for discussion
representative
oxen thank you very much Mr chair yes
I'm a uh co-sponsor on this bill this
was one that was retained last year um
and it was brought forward and we all
felt that it had Merit and we asked the
original sponsors to work on the bill
and bring it back at the beginning of
the session however when the bill saw
the light of day we discovered that
there had been no changes so I agree and
support the notion of itl this is uh we
we we we were in support of a change and
what we got was no change therefore we
should not support
it thank you thank you is there any
further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the motion of
itl on House Bill
294 in one second I shall do just that
hold
on while we're waiting for the clerk to
get ready can I just ask a quick uh
question question of Representative
ssuch will there be a Minority Report on
HB
371 um I I don't think it's necessary
unless someone wants to write one uh
represent man you want to write one on
this yes I'd be willing to do that okay
well then you can write Minority Report
yeah it' be simple thank
you okay thank you
now ask the
clerk call the role on the motion of itl
on
hb29 Mr Clark yes I'm now ready uh we
went through the U discussion executive
session really quickly so that got me
off guard a little bit uh representative
Thomas
yes soon it lets me take your vote there
uh representative Harrington yes
representative nter yes representative M
yes representative CL votes yes
representative bery yes representative
Bernardi yes representative camell yes
representative PL yes representative
white yes representative suuch
yes okay representative Kelly pittz yes
representative man yes representative
Anam yes repres Vincent Yes mcge Yes MC
Williams yes
yes represent I did not hear yes sorry
representative pel yes representative
par yes chairman vot chair votes yes 21
to
nothing thank you by a vote of 21 to
nothing HB 294 is judged to be itl and
without objection I'll put it on the
consent calendar
and representative Bernardi you will
write the uh report for the
committee okay with that we'll close the
executive session on HB
294 and open an executive session on HB
407 I'll recognize uh representative
white for a motion thank youman I'd like
move
that representative white moves itl on
HB 407 I recognize representative
bney uh I second motion representative
gry seconds the motion of itl on HP 407
floor is open for discussion
representative oxam is
recognized the last bill we saw Meritt
in and asked for
changes we didn't get those changes so
we it yiled it this bill is the bill
that has the changes that we
requested I'm flabbergasted that
we're
moving forward with the the notion of
itl where where's that coming
from do we have any explanation for that
motion uh representative white did you
want to make a comment about your motion
this you don't have to if you don't want
to yeah okay no comment okay no
comment okay representative
bee yes thank you Mr chairman um I'm
very surprised with an itl motion and no
explanation of why an itl motion um I
thought this Bill had the support from
the governor when
representative Lang moved forward with
it which is why I was a co-sponsor on it
um because there was
a significant need for some relief in
terms of Municipal net metering and um
and this was the response to that outcry
and it was also supported last time
around when it was um hb12 62 from the
governor's office so I I'm just kind of
shocked that we're thinking this is not
needed when uh all the testimony was to
the contrary so I I'm just trying to
figure out where this comes from why why
would we kill this bill after this is
the third well it's more than the third
year I think but it's at least three
years in the making um so there's not
going to be any explanation you're just
gonna we have no other vehicle so is is
there is it no explanation for why were
this bill is being
killed actually there is um those of you
who were around last year may recall
that at the time uh the original bill I
think it was
1262 was introduced by representative
Cal there was expressed concern by a
couple of people who
testified that
would open up
a wild west market for the sale of
electricity and that there would be no
protections for consumers who engaged in
the purchase of electricity from um
another fellow
Citizen and the concern was
that this Market would be would be
subject to fraud it would be subject to
lawsuits it would be
uh a good concept that would probably
eventually lead
to abuse and it was suggested at the
time that if the bill was ever brought
back that there would be language added
to it that would provide some kind of
consumer protection for people who
engaged in these um in these
transactions between essentially between
private citizens um to me that makes
this bill extremely difficult to
consider passing and u i was hopeful
that when we saw it again there would be
more
language introduced that would provide
some protection for people who want to
do these uh these kinds of one-on-one
person-to-person
transactions but I didn't see that in
this bill and uh so that was the concern
that I had and I know there are other
people who have other concerns about the
bill yeah that's interesting I've been
working on the bill for a while I've
never heard that explanation I've never
heard that concern before um limited
electric energy producers would be
regulated they would not be able to be a
wild wild west the way that you're
characterizing it um I I'm just really
surprised that none of this came up in
the hearing none of these conversations
none of these characterizations of what
it could
do um so you don't remember the
conversations from last year I remember
the conversations around double dipping
and people being able to uh participate
in multiple types of markets or have net
metering as well as being able to sell
and they didn't want people who were
qualified as under the Lepa The Limited
electric energy producer act uh to be
able to participate in those other
markets or they wanted the definition of
what someone was if they were a leap
person uh to be kind of confined and
restricted but this idea that they would
they could commit fraud because of how
they were selling and all that I I I I I
don't I don't understand how how you're
getting there to to say that that that
could happen with this bill that they
that there wouldn't be any regulation of
people who are selling okay thank you
representative
pel thank you Mr chairman uh when we had
the hearings none of the things that you
talked about came
up um you mentioned that they were
talked about in last year's Bill well
this is essentially an amended version
of last year's bill um I mean the
comments that we heard at the um at the
hearings were very fa favorable and once
again we're being asked to itl a bill
based on stuff that was not available to
at the hearing we did not have an
opportunity to ask questions on these
things it just seems um like once again
we're
being uh as to itl a bill which to me
looks like a pretty good bill
thank
you thank you representative
crean thank you um just adding to this
that all the information that I had all
emails that I received on this bill
we're all in support of the bill so I
can't really in good conscience vote to
itl
it thank you uh representative ssuch
um thank you Mr chairman um yeah I too
have received lots of Communications on
this bill and they're all favorable and
if you remember the blue sheet sign up
was 164 for it one person against it
this is a this is a PR loc control Bill
and this is also a bill that gives local
municipalities we're talking
municipalities now not individuals the
opportunity to to make use of instate
Hydro power that they have in their
communities and and towns uh to the
maximum ability uh as a renewable energy
source I don't know why we would be
disparaging our own instate energy
resources uh and not supporting them so
I think itl is a bad
idea uh representative
Thomas thank you Mr chair uh seem to
recall there was some issue about a
property tax
exemption that the bill may have
[Music]
needed I think the bill contains a
property
tax for exemption for
the for for the
actual right right that's right now we
call the the the local utility or
whoever that would be gets a property
tax exemption on this bill as well where
the other utility does not and we've had
many issues before about towns
collecting property taxes from utilities
and so this seems to me that it would be
rather unfair and also would Rob to of
tax doll so the bill does a work and I
think it's just too too much to go on
here so that's another reason why I
was really having trouble understanding
what Doug's saying uh something to do
with his microphone it just comes out
mumbled his microphone isn't real close
here here's another one I don't have a
micone uh what I said was that this bill
contains an exemption for property taxes
on any entity that would be supplying
power uh which you know they function
like a small utility so being exempt
from a U ility property tax again would
be unfair to the other utilities and
also the fact that we rob Talent of tax
dollars and we've had many bills on this
before in the past involving property
taxes on utilities how much are they
assess and so forth and so this bill has
problems along those lines as well uh
and that is a subject that would be way
too difficult to fix on this bill as
well so that's why I also support itl
for that reason is may I may I speak to
that chairman Bose because that's not
accurate
the language that's added to the statute
is do it when it's your
turn representative oxam is in the queue
ahead of ahead of you representative
oxam thank thank you Mr chair um Tom
France of the Pu actually uh was present
at the hearing and and was asked
questions uh by the chair and according
to my notes he was um happy with the
bill he you know did the suggestion that
there's an issue of a possibility of
fraud or lawsuits or this leading to
abuse none of that was raised by the Pu
in fact they felt that the um that this
bill addressed the points that have been
raised last year so I'm again I'm I'm
really flabbergasted by the notion of of
proceeding to an
itl thank you okay now representative
your turn thank you Mr chair and excuse
me for before um when um representative
Thomas mentioned the exemption that came
at the end I did the explanation I have
my written testimony and that section at
the end that is relative to um the
utility prop property tax exclusion def
definition all that is doing is adding
language to
accommodate this new producer with in
the list of of other non utilities that
are producing and adds the word storage
because it is not represented in the
language yet so it's definitional only
and that exemption would go to these
producers because they're not utilities
um they're they're they're generators or
storage but they're not utilities so
they're totally entitled to it um no one
had any testimony to the contrary so I
just wanted to clear that that item up
and the other language above in the bill
from 2 three four five all those
sections talk about how this category of
producer will be treated um through the
Public Utilities Commission so there
it's not a wild west I mean the same
process they're just a different type of
generator and that's all we were trying
to do was add that language to the
statute in in conjunction with all of
the efforts that were made in the prior
two years to get this bill to the point
it was adequate statutorily adequate
language which is what it is
representative Bernardi is recognized
thank you Mr chairman uh so as I look at
that specific language uh that you are
citing 5D it talks about facilities that
are rated up to and including one
megawatt yet this bill as proposed talks
about facilities that are not less than
five megaw so all those facilities
between one and five the comment that uh
representative Thomas Made is is
relevant thank you um that raises a
point I'd forgotten about representative
or The Honorable Cliff B Belo mentioned
when he testified on this bill that the
language about up to an including five
megawatts would be problematic that's
another reason why that's another flaw
of this bill it doesn't say that it says
less than five megawatts this isn't that
bill that had that language that was
problematic that was a different bill
yeah this bill has the correct language
all right thank you uh representative
crean has recognized for a
comment
sorry that was from before I believe
sorry you you forgot to lower your hand
is that what you're saying
okay yeah sometimes it seems to lower on
its own sometimes it doesn't so my
apologies okay no problem representative
MC Williams is
recognized um I have two comments to
make um one is that there was a very
minor Amendment proposed to this it
wasn't formally written by OS but the
minor amendment was to allow
municipalities to cross Municipal lines
uh to better aggregate energy uh and
thought that that was a reasonable
Amendment and I thought that perhaps
that was the direction that this
committee was headed uh because I think
it's really important that we look at
all the testimony we heard and um the
public input on this process we had
145 uh people in support of this bill we
had nine opposing this bill and of those
nine eight were um representatives and
one was Donna gamos from eversource so I
think it's pretty clear when you look at
um the need and the demand from
municipalities they are chopping at the
bit to get this and this is something
that uh our state is very much in favor
of as a global whole so I'm just shocked
that the first thing out of the gate is
an itl rather than a retain with a minor
Amendment thank
you thank you representative
ssuch yes thank you Mr chairman um well
I just wanted to say that uh the
the the sponsor of this bill represent
O'Brien came to us and uh said they were
working collaboratively with their local
utility and that was going fine and it
seems to me that this is another uh
opportunity to appear that the state
wants to control what a local
municipality might want to do with it
with its own resources
so I don't know why we're we're trying
to prevent towns and and and cities from
doing what's best in the best interest
of their population by mandating that
they do it the way we decide it even
though we don't live in that town so I I
think this this is a good
bill we're talking about HP 407 are you
talking about
HP I I am so sorry Mr chairman I mixed
up the bills
okay no problem I I just I just wanted
to be clear about that
yeah okay seeing no further discussion
I'll ask the clerk to call the role on
the motion of itl on HP
407 Mr clerk yes representative
Thoms
yes
oops representative Haring
yes representative n yes representative
mner yes representative PL V yes
representative Baran yes representative
Bernardi yes representative Campell yes
representative BL yes representative
white yes representative of suage no
representative Cy
pittz represent of Cali
Pitts fa question for the chair
is is representative Harrington in the
room is he at in the
L no no he's uh at home then he had to
be there you go you had to be visible to
vote did we not see him when he with
respect to your vote representative Cali
pittz what is
[Music]
it are you muted representative Cali
pittz no I am not
your
vote
oh say it one more time I heard her say
no I I have to hear it from her I heard
oh what is your vote representative
Kelly
Pitts okay thank you representative man
no Representative oam no Representative
Vincent
no represent mcge no represent MC
Williams
no no
pel no
par representative
par
represent okay uh chairman votes chair
votes yes okay that's 11 to 10
[Music]
okay with a vote of 11 to1 the motion to
itl HB 407 passes representative white
you will write the majority opinion
representative ssuch will there be a
minority opinion think represent mgee
are you willing to write the minority
opinion sure reprentative
McGee that'll go on the regular calendar
okay so we're done with HB
407 now we'll turn
to
hb5 excuse me somebody say something I
just wanted to ask um in terms of time
it looks like we only have about 15
minutes left until 5:00 pm is that going
to be enough time for another exact or I
hope okay
I'd like to open the exec session now on
HB
549 that'll do it I will uh recognize
representative CL for a
motion I yes Mr chair i' like to make a
motion to
retain 5
549 representative clog moves to retain
HB
549 representative white is recognized I
would like to second that representative
white seconds the motion to retain HB
549 this uh question is open for
discussion I'll start the discussion by
saying that I requested the committee
this morning when I introduced this bill
to retain it so that we can investigate
whether there might be a
suitably appropriate method to deal with
uh the energy efficiency resource
standard put it into statute and also
deal with a funding mechanism that is
sustainable in the long run so I ask the
committee to retain the bill so that we
can work on what I think would be an
interesting
possibility uh further discussion
representative Pim
Andel thank you uh chairman V do we have
the time to rechange
it it's a pretty complicated
Bill okay thank you for that comment
representative
oxam uh I actually had my qu my hand up
before you opened this session I I had a
question about the the time issue
whether we could have a session on
Friday March 5th because we're going to
be really up against a wall with no
opportunity to discuss and debate if if
we are forced to our next meeting will
be right before
crossover uh that's a good question
what's today the
22nd we might be able to have a meeting
on the on the fifth what what would you
want to do on the
fifth deal with whatever bills are out
standing u i i i I understand you have
to notice particular bills if you you
know what the list is that's still ahead
of us perhaps you could advise us as to
how many bills that
is okay
so uh we have
two that we didn't get to today and then
we have four on the docket for March the
8th so we have six bills to deal
with do you think we need two days to
deal
wow we certain did well it depends if we
have some uh opportunity for a work
session on some of these things instead
of just a executive session Mr
chairman so are you expressing a desire
to have work sessions on the 5th and
then do executive sessions on the
8th I could I could do either one uh it
could be a mix of the two yeah yeah
that's not
bad okay representative Cali
pittz I was I I if you're gonna exec on
the
fifth uh I cancelled one eye surgery
appointment I don't think I can cancel
another
one that's a Friday
right on
the well well Mr chairman how about the
opportunity of having having a work
session on the 5th and executive
sessions on the eth okay I'll take that
under advisement that uh that could work
out uh let me look into that I'll get
back to you thank you uh representative
[Music]
parall representative parall do you have
a comment on the motion to retain HB
549 no I have a question that sherff
forgive me uh I had March 1st as a work
day as well but I understand we're not
meeting on the
1 we don't have uh time to notice March
1 we could only notice March 5th thank
you for that fine fine thank
you
yeah no I forgot to put it down
okay thank you uh seeing no further
discussion on HP 549 I would ask the
clerk to call the role on the motion to
retain HB 549 Mr
[Music]
clerk okay
that okay representative Thomas yes
representative Harrington yes
representative ner yes representative uh
mner
yes representative Plex votes yes
representative Bary yes representative
Bernardi yes representative cber yes
representative Pro yes representative
white yes representative suuch yes
representative Kelly pittz yes
representative man yes representative
oxam yes Representative
Vincent Yes representative McGee yes
represent MC Williams yes represent
incretion yes was that a yes yes
representative pel yes representative
par yes and the chair chair votes yes 21
to
nothing okay by a vote of 21 to nothing
HB 549 is retained will that go in the
consent it doesn't go on the calendar at
all retain I got it it never Lees the
committee so it was a dumb question all
right I think that's enough uh work for
one day and I will um have a discussion
with uh our committee researcher and our
committee admin to find out if we can
schedule and also the U the house uh
scheduler to find out if we can schedule
a meeting for March 5th at which we
would conduct work sessions on probably
six bills
uh and then follow that up on Monday
March 8th with a exec session on those
six bills so I will let you all know by
email the outcome of
that
exploration and um possibly we will see
you on Friday
March 5th I will remind all of you that
the house is in session this
Wednesday February 21 4th from 9 in the
morning until 6: in the evening at the
sports
complex the house meets again on
Thursday February 25th which just
happens to be my
birthday happy birthday house will be in
section from 9 until two on the 25th
representative Harrington did you have a
comment uh just a question when you send
that out we give us the all the numbers
of the six builds too to make sure we're
on the same
page say that again I didn't question
you send the numbers of the bills the
six bills that we have remaining so
everybody can look at them in advance oh
yes absolutely probably the uh the
numbers and the title of the bill I'll
send it
all okay uh if there is nothing else
then I encourage everybody to drive
carefully in the snow on your way home
everybody who's here all of you at home
I'll look forward to seeing you on
Wednesday and Thursday at the sports
complex thanks everybody good job see
you later yeah that was by safe out
there by